two welcome
everybody to the h3 podcast experience
today's episode is sponsored by tushy
and ridge
wallets uh today's episode we
are joined by william osman and his wife
chelsea osman we recorded that earlier
today
it was a fantastic episode it is a
fantastic episode
about two dysfunctional men and their
social care their wives who are social
workers
they're basically assigned to us by the
uh municipality
to keep us straight and honest
right uh i wasn't i was fascinated by
the similarities between us frankly
because
we both for example have piles of
laundry in our room before we
met our significant other so that we
have in common
i wonder if all guys do that though if
that's just a guy thing
do you guys have ever have a pile of
laundry in your room i mean i've gotten
better about it over the years
i gotta say when you uh when you brought
that up though
um in my mind i was like why don't you
just throw it in the closet and then
that turned out that's where it was yeah
so you know it's funny
yeah we were talking that ela when she
first came here from israel
um she was saying that she was horrified
by my giant pile of laundry and then i
was realizing that i had just
shoved it all in my closet and then
realizing that i never used my closet
i never hung a single thing in my closet
on the floor yeah
the only thing i used it for was
stuffing clothes in there so the room
looked clean when you arrived
yeah we've come a long way haven't we
mm-hmm i can use hangers now and
everything yeah they do use hangers now
absolutely um
anyway we had a really fun time a really
good conversation i think it was
a beautiful a wonderful time that i
think everybody will enjoy
before we get to that i want to do a
couple of
announcements help help is on the way
we are giving away a hundred thousand
clams
sugar mommies does anyone call money
sugar mommies not really
think so we are giving away 100 000
doll 150 000 dollar hairs thanks to the
generosity of
brendan green so three winners
every day gets picked for a hundred days
five hundred dollars per person fifteen
hundred dollars
per day all you gotta do is retweet
my daily post and put your paypal link
it's still going
on we're on day like 60 something 65.
when this comes out tomorrow it will be
68.
so we still have a good amount of you
know over 30 days left of uh giveaways
so make sure
if you want to get some free money we
are doing this by the way of course
because of the pandemic
and everyone's out of work so we're
trying to figure out what which way we
can best help people so
if you are looking for a little help
that's
that's our way of trying to give back
although i have to say i'm amused by the
amount of conspiracies
that i see in the threads yeah people go
uh you're only giving away to bots i saw
someone go
i swear they go like yesterday all the
winners started with tea
and they go all the winners start with
you know when i saw that when i did the
drawing and they're all tea
i was like that for sure is gonna that's
gonna trigger somebody there's like a
small group of dedicated conspiracy
theorists
for sure that are always like but i
promise you
uh the money is there it's being given
away it just goes to show you
there's never a good deed there's no
good deed in this world you know
and then actually what's the shittiest
thing is that the people that actually
went start getting harassed
oh great and told that they're bots
great pretty much every time there's a
winner they go i'm not a bot
because everyone thinks that either
people are scamming us or we're scamming
them
they just know there's a scam evolved um
but it can't be possibly just a random
good thing
that's happening no no no no no ela back
up
no there's real money and real winners
every day so
that's that another thing i want to
announce before we get to the interview
with william is that teddy fresh just
came out with a new collection
teddyfresh.com
finally the june look and i have to say
that i think this is
probably our most refined drop
ever we've been um working on some of
these pieces for so long and then
especially with kovid
it all got delayed so
it feels really good to finally put
something out
and from now on they're gonna keep
coming but this collection i feel like
first of all like we've got the
basketball jersey patchwork i mean it
just came out so beautiful
the shorts sandals are first shoes we
called them combat ready sandals
obviously
you're gonna wanna fight in the trenches
with those things i wanna show the box
that it comes in because i thought
oh here let me click it then in that
case comes with
a freaking box
there you go eelo uh
some i saw some female
demand for smaller sizes we
unfortunately
didn't we didn't know how it was going
to do
and so we didn't want to just make like
so many
sizes because it's just kind of like a
test run for us
so we will continue to make more and
we will add more then that's true you
know we're working on a female
collection our first female colleague
yeah so
in the future there's going to be a lot
more attention to our female
to our beautiful female customers our
wonderful females that we love so much
just enough no not like a weirdo not too
much yeah not too much
so we've got this my mom the patchwork
i love this shirt cam is a masterwork i
mean look at this
unbelievable a bandana giddy up perfect
timing for
the uh face covering if you need a face
covering a shirt with a pocket on it we
call this one
and i have to say this is made probably
our most comfortable
t-shirt ever made it's just a beautiful
shirt why
i keep clicking wrong and it just i
don't know how do you click
wrong it's all the grease on the uh
track pad i'm pretty sure
see they don't know what you're yeah i
don't want to spoil anything people stay
tuned for the grease
big ass chenille hoodie bear scratch
lots of striped tees these are all super
comfortable super great yeah
and so that is that that's our
collection so head on over to
teddyfresh.com if you want to uh buy
some clothing
with that being said let's jump right in
to the show with william oh and one more
this was actually i made it one time
just for the podcast
like i um i had this crew neck that i
wore inside out and i just wrote hi mom
on it i don't know if you remember
i do i just thought it was so funny that
my mom will watch
the podcast and she'll see him oh i
didn't realize it was for your mom
so that um started out this piece
which is was really fun to work on it's
reversible me open it up
hi mom and then the back is by mom yeah
and then if you keep going down
this is basically the the normal side
if you flip it inside out yeah you get
two sides
cabbage it's like a two for one yeah
it's a great deal i'm telling you um so
there you have it
uh oh i remember people in the comments
being like i want that high mom buy mom
and then so we duplicated it so it
looked like her markers
anyway yeah so guys
let's get into today's episode with
william
and chelsea osman enjoy
okay and with us today
is william and chelsea osman
joining us via gatsby
oh god is your foot okay
it's loud yeah they can hear it it's
just quiet for us
i mean that is a very american haircut i
will say it fits the
aesthetic you nicked your foot are you
okay
did it hurt that was there don't worry
leave this here yes you could you want
to back it out
yeah you can back it up how are you
doing chelsea
this kind of abuse okay there we go
it's not very cinematic when they have
to back it out it's like they
they drive in and then they back it out
it's not very uh
and now they walk in hey oh they're back
wow what an entrance what an entrance
thank you guys
well what a pleasure what a joy
yeah is it too cold we just fixed the ac
yeah last week it wasn't working i'm
gonna turn it
i have a jacket you're in the coldest
seat i'm not gonna do that i'm prepared
to put a jacket like this last week it
was like a hundred degrees here
so um everybody we are in close
proximity and a closed room i don't
think this is uh
recommended by health experts i've been
trying to figure out how do you do any
of this stuff now like
well we were tested recently yeah and i
know that uh
you guys well you definitely had kovid
for sure
yeah 100 william i think you must have
had it said i did but
you must have we got tested later with
the the secondary test
we got him the antibody test when it was
first available like the day it was
available
we went and got the test um and then we
got the results back the next day mine
came back positive his was negative
but they also said this is not a very
reliable test right that's what i heard
so
dude you had yeah you had covet we're
going to definitely get him retested
well let me ask you this during the
period which you were
sick or leading up to it a week how much
uh
stuff was going on like like how bad it
was it or
no i mean like the how cl what was the
proximity of you
you two guys i mean we were literally
living in the same house
yeah like right do the math you had to
you have we held
hands at least three times
we were definitely what they told me was
well they told me a lot of really strict
things like can you guys use separate
bathrooms i said no we're remodeling our
bathrooms so like that's going to help
they were really like okay almost
comical like they advised that they
yeah they said use separate bathrooms
and they said and when you're in the
bathroom don't use a hand
towel put paper towels you throw away
what don't share hand towels
and i'm like ah that's so sweet sure but
i'm like i wash my hand towels at least
once a week because i'm
super like clean and ocd
yeah i have ocd whoa whoa once a week is
not ocd
no well compared to that that's pretty
normal yeah
but my my standards are very high to
begin with
so and they told us to they said can you
sleep in separate rooms and i said i was
all for that i
didn't want to do this in new york don't
they recommend to use a glory hole
oh did you guys hear that no no i swear
to god
yeah paul can you pull that up dan in
new york uh they said
well they first gave out their first
release like a couple months ago
and they said uh no [ __ ] they said
don't
remember they were like really all the
things
their conference yeah call like trying
to figure okay what's the public notice
we put out
and that comes up on the table they put
a lot of emphasis on ramming but then
they put out a new statement and they
said
we recommend putting a they said uh
the exact verbiage dam will pull up but
a wall
a wall between you phil yeah
avoid kissing and obviously no like
sexual activity
and i'm like i can't breathe everything
hurts
i'm tired i have diarrhea um
that's not gonna be a problem for me
like yeah that's okay but i didn't feel
like i wanted to sleep in a different
room because the only thing that made me
feel like kind of better was like
at least that i had my husband nearby
and he was checking my breathing and
stuff like that
yeah was one where i like poked my head
in the room because she she was going to
bed much earlier like
sleeping half the day and kind of poke
in i'm like oh she's still breathing
yeah she's breathing then i would go
back out and do whatever i was doing
because
it definitely got to that point where
where i was sort of thinking like
what do i do i call like do i because
you know like when do you go to the er
when you cut your arm off when you're
someone's unconscious and they hit their
head against the wall but like in this
case
like i don't know like do you wait until
someone's like completely stopped
breathing like what's the
you know no one tells you they tell you
not you know to to
be careful with [ __ ] but they don't
tell you like at what point you call
yourself what's the point do you go to
the e it was very early you had it so
early
that while i was watching your video
about it and it was it was really
frustrating i i can only imagine
what you guys felt going through it yeah
i mean they told you you guys went there
to get tested for covet
yeah and they told you that you didn't
test for the flu
you were having flu-like symptoms yeah
and then there instead of them being
like oh you have covet they said you
have a cold
yeah why well based on what why would
they say that just
based on it i mean honestly i think it
was so early they had no information
and i think they were afraid of giving
information that then you could maybe
use against them like oh we told this
person they might have covid
and then they didn't so they're going to
come be angry i think there was just a
lot of fear
it was a lot of fear early on which i
felt a lot of fear
too um once i knew i had it because i'm
like is ever going to be mad at me
because the media was like
attacking a lot of people unless you're
a celebrity
it was a lot of negativity um so it was
i i'm guessing that they were playing on
that manner the lady we had though when
they tested me for the flu she was very
um angry very she didn't like william oh
yeah
why what did you do oh yeah yeah i mean
that kind of makes sense but yeah but
it's your wife i know
whose privacy are they protecting i
don't know right she but i mean after
that
she just sent like another person that
was like
i want to verify that you're not feeling
like i was right i was pleading when she
was
like just get it away from me i just
want to get tested i feel so bad and
he's like
i think he ended up putting it on this
yeah yeah that was good it's important
to document that i think so too like
yeah
yeah why would you not you know so if
they were going to just say you had
like at what point did they say yeah you
have coveted you need to be careful and
protect those around you yeah
why did they come out in this hazmat
suit and all this serious [ __ ]
just to tell you you had a cold right
it's stupid it was and then i ended up
getting the call
from you know the person i got it from
the next day so we i got the flu test
that saturday and then it was monday
that i got the cove
the thing that was crazy to me is like
we we're just we're lucky because she's
a teacher right and so she's not in
school when this happened and like i
don't i mean you know how it is when you
make videos online like you just stay
home all day
yeah and so we're in a situation where
it's like you get tested and they're
like oh well
you probably have the cold but stay home
just in case but like if someone told me
how to i had a cold
and i had that like i you know i got to
pay my bills and go to work like yeah
i'm gonna go to work
yes and i'm going to pay my bills
because i don't have it
why would i act like i did you know
unless someone
for sure told me or they tested me for
it it seems unethical
it was bad you know like in our
situation it wasn't that bad because we
could deal with it but in someone else's
situation they're just like no i'm just
gonna go
work at you know wherever you work yeah
and then my school also
closed officially so that that friday
well i started showing symptoms thursday
night i called out sick to work
it wasn't at work on friday my school
was closed by monday i mean it was just
like okay we're shut down
further notice and you know keep post
we'll keep you posted are they close are
they still closed yeah so technically
today's my last day of school
um oh congratulations
no wait no uh 12. um so i'm not
so you you continue to get paid and is
there any um
is there any uh requests on your ti do
they presume you to do any work or are
you oh yeah
oh yes oh they do what kind of work are
you doing we're still being paid full
time so we're still working
full time so it's called distance
learning
online distance learning so i teach
fifth grade so i was using google
classroom
google meets videos some people are
using zoom
assigning work doing videos oh this is
kind of like a free-for-all where they
like they're kind of like they sort of
give you some guidance but they're for
them there was
good luck figure it out it was just so
quick though i mean how do you give
guidance when
we're at school on a friday come monday
we were like okay now we're on this
emergency
we have to follow the governor we have
to follow cdc we have to follow ventura
county public health
um you know all these different things
like depending on where you're at so it
was immediate
my district it was um it was a little
bit i think maybe
easier because we were about to go on
spring break so we had these weeks
before to kind of prepare
and then we had two weeks spring break
now i worked during that time because
you're contacting parents and you're
emailing and you're texting you're
getting
all hours of the day because because
parents couldn't just change their
schedule overnight like
okay now i'm gonna change my work hours
so i can be a full-time at home
apparently i mean it didn't work like
that so we worked the whole time
and it was very uh like the crazy part
is a lot of the
because she's in like the lowest income
district like i don't know how they
schedule that stuff and so
like a lot of the kids don't have
internet oh wow yeah
so we had that was a big thing again
that two-week spring break was
great because we were able to get
information gather
who needs uh you know hot spots who
doesn't it's like a logistical nightmare
on top of just teaching the kids like
there was so much stuff
i can't believe there's kids in ventura
county that don't have
internet oh there's many many many wow
yeah in my district alone
yes it was a huge and then we we gave
them hot spots
and there were still issues because what
happens when you have the hots is i mean
you guys are all aware of it but our
families weren't
you know if you have brother streaming
netflix and sister
playing video games and then the one kid
that i have that's like trying to listen
to class
all the stuff is being used and so
they're like i can't hear you you're
breaking up because all the internet's
been used or all the bandwidth's been
used that day
so it was a huge issue that's why
internet needs to be a
yeah yeah a uh somewhat controlled what
do you call it
utility it should be edged pie
you [ __ ] us all we were going that's
the fcc they literally had to go to you
know
networks like they didn't even use like
the local internet providers like they
went to a cell network because that was
like the easiest thing to do
huh you know well now some some cell
phone company is like making a bunch of
money off the district
and we just collected them that's what
we were doing this week was collecting
back
technology chromebooks ipads hot spots
and all that and our work we're
frantically trying to figure out what
are we going to do for next year that's
going to be better because
this was we tried our best and that's
better than nothing
but it wasn't the best and kids didn't
receive
as much equity as they should have of
course yeah and it wasn't anyone's
intention it was just
you can't predict or control home lives
and
you can't tell okay i can see your
brother in the background playing call
of duty like
what do you get you can't go in there
and get him with like oh yeah well i
mean it's a pretty good use of the
hospital i know
yeah i mean that's a hard argument today
okay i was required to do an
hour and a half they had to have an hour
and a half of work and this was like
mandated by you know the state like okay
this age should be doing this much so
they could have waited to do that well
to uh to backtrack a little bit i do
have the uh guidelines from new york
city
regarding sexual activity yeah yeah so
take note because this
applies to all of us make it a little
kinky they say
be creative with sexual positions and
physical barriers like walls
[Laughter]
that allow sexual contact while
preventing close face-to-face contact
is that why the lines at home depot were
so long just a ton of drywall
everyone's got like this dude i gotta be
honest there's literally nobody doing
that right
no [ __ ] throw a hole absolutely not
i will not no not because of that they
were already doing it if they were doing
it exactly
yeah if that was someone's you know
desire that wouldn't happen before cut a
couple of holes
oh my goodness um
so so tell me what was the i mean
do you feel you fully recovered from
covet because yeah at this point i do
i feel like i have a hundred percent
lung capacity
you know my muscles like no fatigue all
that but
what really kicks your butt the like for
is it takes a long time to get back to
your normal lung capacity
so the the first two weeks were severe
and then the next two weeks
you're just trying to cooperate like the
night where i was like poking my head in
to see if she was still breathing which
sounds pretty bad
uh that was it was immediately better
after that
like the next day was it was because it
had kind of progressed to like
i want to say like maybe half lung
capacity where she was like that's bad
you know and then it would like be
painful and then the next day would just
get you know
it would it was better did you take any
medicine where you just saw nyquil or
anything
they said they didn't know no they just
i'm like looking at it ibuprofen no they
said don't take ibuprofen no
they told me i couldn't i remember their
flip-flopping
but then they called them and said it's
okay if i take them they're like yeah
there's
there's thumbs up what the [ __ ] do we
know yeah you have a cold but yeah
i tried taking instead of i think i
tried taking tylenol
so i think they said don't take tylenol
anything really the tylenol i would take
because i was taking ibro and it would
give me some relief from the
severe body pain because that was the
worst part of me and so i tried the
tylenol when there was like some studies
coming out
and i had zero res i'm like i feel just
as bad
so i switched back to ibuprofen i don't
really care if they say it's bad
it gives me relief so i can kind of
function
somewhat so i could sleep that was what
it was i couldn't sleep
because i was in so much pain but if i
could take ibuprofen i could get myself
into a position and
actually fall asleep gotta take it yeah
so i did
good and then they came out you know a
week later okay yeah no ibuprofen's fine
it's
you can take it so do you know how you
caught it yeah
how'd you catch it so i caught it um
from my therapist so i was at an
appointment uh with her
uh monday the 9th and we're in a
you know her office she has two couches
i didn't
we don't shake hands we don't hug
anything like that she opens the door
wow sat down we had an hour long session
of course this was before we had
guidelines
you guys were probably even further away
than we are now oh yeah definitely
by far and um you know having a normal
hour-long session talking
you know normally like you do um and
then she
opens the door i mean the payment's
electron every there's no
touching that's incredible that it's
that contagious that just sitting across
you guys are probably six feet apart i
mean you don't see it that close right
right no yeah it was probably
i would say approximately maybe like the
closed room
you found out that she had it so she
contacted she
somehow was able to get tested like i
think she had a friend or something that
where she was able to like force herself
to get tested she's also a force to be
reckoned with you're not gonna tell her
no she's gonna
get things done well she's she's knows
what she's doing and she's a
professional and she knows
that i've seen many patients she had to
force
her getting a test and then once she had
it and she got the results
which was you know what's that a week or
something
then she calls all the clientele and
says you have and then
we tried to get tested that's no no that
was we tried to get tested they tested
me for the flu
and i found out two days later from her
that she was positive we went to urgent
care
without knowing anything then her
therapist called her and then we went
and said like she's a teacher she's just
been at school
she's been in contact and i called my
primary yeah then they said
okay we'll do it wow you basically had
to have like
almost guaranteed early on you had to
have people yeah
with someone who was positive they
wouldn't test you that's so
so what do you think about the situation
now as someone who's been through it
i mean the early the early reaction that
our government had was
was obviously uh yeah a tragic it's a
conflict of interest right because like
if you react too strong
i i think the problem in general like
it's really sad because
like i've described this to people that
like humans are really good
at analyzing situations at certain time
scales right so like if you're like
dealing something really fast
it's hard to deal with if you're dealing
with something like in the seconds range
it's pretty easy to deal with when
you're dealing with something on like
the really long
time range you think that it would be
even easier to deal with but it's
actually the opposite
so it's like the government has to make
a choice about what they think is going
to happen
and if if it works and they made the
right choice
nothing happens but people lose the
feeling of concern and then they get mad
at the choice
and so there's no feedback that
validates the correct decision
right they're calling it like yeah
everyone's feeling fatigued from
isolating right and it just you know
people begin to feel like we're being
suppressed as opposed to we are taking
action to prevent something from
happening and so it's like
very difficult to kind of recognize that
it did do anything yeah
i heard so it's very frustrating and
it's also hard for people
if they don't know someone personally
it's hard for them it just feels
so i mean my brother told me he was at
the grocery store even this was less
than a month ago and
the guy behind him in line was just like
oh yeah this is being blown on
proportion i don't know anyone that's
had it this is
and my brother turned around was like um
my sister had it so can you
like shut it while you're in public
right now because i find what you're
saying really offensive
and incorrect and you know dangerous to
be talking like that and the guy was
like oh i'm you know i'm sorry
right but that's going around constantly
yeah it's turned into a political issue
which is so weird because
i mean this is just a public health
issue
the whole thing about wearing masks and
people we did a whole segment here where
there was people who were
crying because they couldn't go into a
grocery store without a mask right
and um and it's just so bizarre we're so
bizarre
we have you know like family in other
parts of the country who who kind of act
like that too and it's just like
they're just getting bad information
that's like that's the kind of person
that you can sort of reason with and
have a discussion
is also usually not the person that
behaves like that like how are you
supposed to have
how are you supposed to like have you
know like a debate where maybe somebody
learns something or thinks about
something a different way
it's bad info dude there's nothing to do
that's that's kind of the problem but
look at this [ __ ]
i just want to show you guys because
i've been following this very closely i
don't know if you can
frequent this website yeah yeah i love
this
and how ours is uh plateaued and then
increasing
mm-hmm here we pull up then you look at
other colors yeah all the other
countries are like
down here italy china south korea japan
all the countries that had a
bad outbreak in america baby we are
crushing it
yeah by the way this is the news this
was expected
[ __ ] off with all these pop-ups so
here's the thing
this was expected to drop off in the
summer because everybody's outdoors and
the virus doesn't do well outdoors and
in the sun
and then it was it will get rid of it
and yeah it will magically disappear
and so and so we were expected to really
have a total drop-off during the summer
and then a resurgence during the fall
right but because people are literally
not
everyone's just back to life as usual
you can see
now in still in june we're almost back
up to our peak numbers
27 000 and trying to reopen just seems
impossible because you have this and so
plans are like okay we have a
stage one two three four five we're
getting up to those stage three four and
we're gonna have to go backwards and say
oh yeah schools
we're planning on four scenarios for the
fall
which is going to be 100 distance
learning
50 25 or
normal which is like that's a hail mary
that's not going to happen but we have
to be ready
because we don't know with numbers what
we'll be able to do you guys are like
the military you've got like strategies
right
it's insane we have a lot of library
like they have to figure out
you guys we got to put you teachers in
charge of everything man
because you know what about when this
happened teachers
overnight or like we're doing online and
i'm not saying that it went great
but at least it was better than okay
parents you have your kids now for an
extra four months
at least we just and teachers overnight
this happened i mean
i was sick with coronavirus writing
lesson plans
watching youtube videos getting ready
gearing up i mean thank you for your
service i've complained about it thank
you
like the older teachers who have trouble
logging into their email and stuff so
like now imagine
that's true yeah
well that's true there's a lot of old
teachers right they've really been
trying they're great people
you know but they you're not they don't
understand zoom then it puts like a
burden on her
you know when she's trying to help other
people oh [ __ ]
yeah i feel really bad for the kids
because it's
it's such a weird environment for them
it's so
especially and they have all this energy
and they need to get out
and do so yeah and they're gonna learn
like they're gonna grow up especially
these little ones like
no no don't touch don't share when
that's what we teach in school you learn
social
cues and how to get along and how to be
fair and how to
you know all these things that you're
going how do we do that
with distancing and to be how do we
teach
you know safety and health is important
but right
all these other things and when does all
the like the sort of new rules and stuff
go away like when is it sort of safe i
mean look at like all the 911 stuff
where you're still
it's very difficult to try to go back
years years years because everyone's
scared you know like even if you
technically don't need it anymore
everybody's like afraid to make a
decision yep and we're creating a lot of
anxiety
and kids and of course adults but the
kids because they don't know how to
differentiate
and kind of compartmentalize okay well
these are the things where i need to
these are things like it the social
emotional issues have skyrocketed
in districts i mean i know how my
school's been affected how my grade
level
my students that is huge and we already
we have one counselor
at our school of over 700 kids wow
you know and the issues now every year
have been increasing with this
they're going to skyrocket well we have
one counselor
and we might be losing funding i mean
it's just these are things that wait
you're losing funding why their
potential
for what for just for a budget cut or
something else yeah
yeah so please call your congress is it
is it who's cutting the budget the state
or the federal government both yeah so
calling into both
both have colluded to cut funding
further from schools
there's because we've been in declining
enrollment we've had like in california
specifically we've had declining
enrollment so there's been a lot of
budgetary issues so this year alone we
had to cut two and a half million from
my district
and i'm not you know our district's not
alone in this we're potentially gonna
have to cut eight million
next year if people don't call i mean
we've been doing campaigns
all called it's already affecting like
our health insurance
and everyone else's health insurance
yeah our our health insurance already is
going up
like we just got an official email from
our you know superintendents last night
and they're like
we want to keep negotiating but as of
right now this is what here's our cap
here you know that's crazy
is not that much when you consider the
entire budget of the federal and state
government
how is that not a priority million this
year resulted in cutting 30
jobs and we were super lucky to get a
huge retirement
um you know initiative so we had a lot
of retirees
so only nine teachers you know in our
district got laid off but it's gonna be
they'll spend a bunch of money because
it's more
efficient to try to get rid of like the
the high end
the guys who are getting paid more yeah
like if you can get them to retire early
by incentivizing them then that will
sort of
school should be flush with money and
then next year we're going to need
more people we're going to need more
councils we're going to need more nurses
we're going to need
smaller settings and then you're going
to cut our budget i mean i don't know
every time we do taxes it's like that
little form of like uh
how much money for teachers did you
spend this year and you get up to 250
dollars off and it's like
oh yeah yeah i don't know it's comical
yeah and i
actually don't even know how much money
she spends she has to spend a lot of
time oh yeah
you know what's funny and trump's uh his
his tax cut
bill he limited the amount of money
teachers can deduct
for [ __ ] supplies they buy more than
200 it's less yeah it was
well before you could deduct anything
you wanted as a business expense correct
me if i'm wrong no i think it was it was
a tuner
there was a little otherwise there was a
limit so is it less than that 250.
oh it's yeah it's it's insane and this
is a district where like you know
the families are really poor and so you
have to either fight the school for
stuff like which could even include like
you know sometimes paper and things like
that
um paper you get so much it's like
you're you're
you're you're for the year your budget
for the year if you go over it
cleaning supplies like clorox wipes and
stuff well we're
technically not allowed to have those in
our room yeah but sometimes you gotta
you get clorox i do though because we
eat breakfast in our classrooms
so yeah those are like very i'm also in
the union so i
probably i know a lot more yeah
i'm very active in our union but yeah
well it's
basically everybody spends their own
money like you have to because if you
just need something
well like i'm not going to try to like
waste a bunch of time
well it's a good thing you are highly
paid
isn't that [ __ ] up that in america
they they
they count on the general these people
like you
caring about the kids more than they do
about their own like that yep
i help her all the time
yeah you you can't solve all the
problems and at the end of the day like
you can't have a perfect solution you
just have to have the best solution
and you're not gonna like save everyone
you're not gonna like you're always
gonna have those troubled kids that you
know cause you
you know the most grief that you feel
bad of like you can't help them almost
what do we do this is not okay i feel
like i don't know
like do we take do you think taking
money from the police
and putting it towards school and
community things yes yeah
yeah and and and like education after
school programs
mental health that cuts down on crimes
all of that yeah they're solving the
problem
right now i can have in my classroom
with with about 30 kids
approximately four of them are able to
get into the free program
after school because it's so the limited
space dude crime will
definitely go down with after school
that's proven and put them in
and offer sports with why do you need to
pay to put your kid in soccer no way are
you
are you telling me that after school
programs are better for society than
police tanks correct you telling me
you're going to take tanks away from the
police
take the tanks away take all their extra
like shields and weapons whatever
you give all these fancy well hang on
that's a terrible one
[Laughter]
are you telling me that police don't
need grenade launchers they do not i
think the kids
should have the crate yeah let's at
least share those would have loved this
as a child he was
always a mad scientist yo our country is
so [ __ ] in the ass
it's there's a i think there's this is
so bad it's really bad
it's terrible and and it's really
difficult to try to explain these things
to people who are so against like
they're like
you're gonna defund the police we're
gonna know police officers it's gonna be
so dangerous i feel like
it's not we're just taking some tanks
away we're just we're
cashing in tanks for some paper
like and coaches and you know
i can be like teachers i would be at
least if i can do an after school i'll
be a coach
i'm not great but it's better than
nothing and of course the better
you know the better train we have the
you know here you want to hear how pe
works gosh
yes i'd love to i mean pe physical
education
do they what is that what about yeah
they have one pe teacher for like the
entire district
specialist that comes once a week it's a
program
it's a great great program if you can
get it all the time it's called sparks
pe and it's like an acronym
it's wonderful but we get her once a
week
but there's other people so i changed
well she had you yeah i teach pe
but you also teach other things or i'm a
multiple subject so i teach everything
in elementary school
really so just imagine like i teach pe
those are mandated minutes other
teachers
teach right it's sort of like subjected
to like who the teacher
is they're just like everybody teaches
pe here right and some teachers might do
less than others and so it's
you know yeah and some teachers because
it takes time right so it's like if
you're behind on other stuff like pe is
the thing that you're gonna forget about
and now you have all these budget cuts
like is that person even going to be
able to give the kids like
it's not even you once a week right it's
like the school gets it once a week so
you have to trade
it's my grade level gets it one week of
the year
oh that's it's like why do you even
having what one week of the year
my grade level gets it one week of the
year because she goes to all the schools
in the district and she's doing the same
thing so she has
her schedule is full the beginning of
the year one week at this goal and this
grade one we get the
she's doing all the districts and this
is like when you do like the big like
like a flappy tarp thing right the cool
fun stuff yeah the parachutes and like
they're really fun like where you have
the hula hoops or you have the
the fuzz balls the kind of thing that
makes kids like excited to come to
school
yeah and she's awesome um and i just
i know that other districts have that
program you know they get it every week
every single week
but it's all about monies and funding
and when we're looking at our budget of
like
they do that every week with a freaking
club some districts do if they have more
money
which is just from property tax right
more affluent area and then you get
donation
there's all kinds of ways that you can
kind of you know make the numbers work
unfortunately we have other priorities
in our district that
come first and yeah if we lose more and
every year we're like losing more budget
we haven't even recovered from the 2008
recession at schools
and now we're going to be you know
losing money again we haven't even
brought back all the arts programs all
the music programs it's like they're
starting to
slightly come back just a little snippet
a little taste
a little little dab of it and it's just
you know potentially going to go
away again and people are like what
keeps kids in school
music art sports you know all the things
that i remember
in middle school where you went to bel
boa
where would you have gone to middle yes
okay that's where i went i went to
cabrillo balboner
yeah what do they call cabrillo what did
i do balboa was the [ __ ] i didn't think
about cabrillo i just thought they're
all weirdos i was closer
to them that was like a thing though
like there was nicknames for all the
middle schools
yeah and a crappa isn't it so weird like
in ventura there was like two competing
high schools yeah and i thought i went
to uh
uh buena yeah how do you forget that
dude it's been [ __ ] so long bro
oh my god and then what was the other
one uh ventura that's where you went
no i well that's where i was supposed to
go they built a magnet school oh you
went to the what was that called
yeah foothold and then you were the
dragon so here so
i thought the ventura kids were so weird
it's like a bizarro you
yeah you guys fans of seinfeld you know
the bizarro seinfeld episode
it's like that and then foothill was
just a bunch of weirdos yeah
that one yeah that was true we were the
ones i mean our mascot was a dragon
though so it's pretty cool
i remember feeling that way about kids
from other schools yeah
it's like just rained in you now you see
them you like see them on the streets
and you're like we would have buena nerd
days
like they'd have bueno nerd days or
ventura like depending where you went
and even at foothill
the magnet school because i did sports
that when
i did i did tennis i was terrible but
you could dress up for nerd days and you
picked what school
so i would dress up as a buena nerd and
other people would dress up
why would you do that because that's
rude because i did
that you know all those things
it's like it's just in great and that's
the school's encouragement it's so funny
though how like
the tribalism like i played water polo
in high school and we when we competed
against ventura was like these
[ __ ] i don't know you actually
want to hurt you yeah
it's gonna be a dirty game oh yeah they
are but
they make you check your like nails and
stuff because yeah my cousin she's on
the girls water polo team at ventura and
they check your nails but they don't
check your toenails and she's like oh my
gosh
just really some of the stuff i've heard
her say how old does she know
oh how 13 no she's not 13. she's going
into her junior year
i've heard like she said like some of
these people are just nasty
yeah underwater like trying to draw each
other yeah yeah yeah
well so one of the things is they pull
the speedos off yeah a lot of
water polo players will wear multiple
speedos so it's like
you can't lose your trunks and then
another thing they do is like if
someone's swimming
in front of you you grab their leg and
try to pull them underwater
but it's like then you get into the mind
games where if somebody's behind you
then you pretend like they grabbed your
foot
like a professional soccer player it's
all part of the game oh my god
yeah but it's it's pretty we gotta go to
dan was that a sound bite because it was
very quiet it was a sound bite but it
was that can you play it again
oh so sorry to interrupt we got to go to
break okay
all right we are going to throw it to a
quick break when we come back there is
more william and chelsea
osman
you poop you wash you dry it's a
three-step process
tushy is in the business of blasting ass
with water wiping your butt with dry
toilet paper does not remove
all the [ __ ] i love this copy
uh if you got poop on any other part of
your body would you just wipe it off in
dry paper
that's a really good point it is such a
good water cleans way better
than dry paper my friends thankfully
there's now a sleek bidet attachment
that clips onto your existing toilet
sprays your butt completely clean with
fresh water and it's called
tushy and it's the best thing you could
do for your butt
tushy sprays directly to at your ass
and removes the poop completely so you
aren't sitting on bacteria that leads to
nasty things like hemorrhoids
yeast infections utis or itchy buttholes
or skid marks if you're a grown man with
skid marks and itchy [ __ ] you need
toshi because you ain't cleaning right
buddy but days are common in the rest of
the world
a bidet saves you money on toilet paper
and you
uh if you still maybe a little toilet
paper but it's a very negligible amount
i'm talking a roll will last you a
lifetime a dab will do you
it won't clog your toilets until she
sprays your ass with fresh water it's
not toilet water it connects
to the water supply behind your toilet
to spray your dirty parts with clean
fresh water it's the same water you
brush your teeth with guys you guys come
on
wet wipes are worse than toilet paper as
we've learned on the show
they're terrible for the environment and
they cause anal
fissures i don't want my anus fissuring
do you
oh and here's the best part it's only 79
why aren't you guys trying the miracle
of tushy
79 helps you get everything out it's
like a sexy
oh and then they have an ottoman as well
which apparently helps if you put your
feet up it helps [ __ ]
it helps get everything out it's a sexy
tooth or cloud that helps you poop
they've described it as
and it's only 69 as well so not bad
so if you want you got to get those
tushies boy go to hellotushy.com
h3h3 to get 10 off
your order hellotushy.com
h3h3
this video is brought to you by ridge
wallets it's a
light sleek and industrious beautiful
wallet for the new
age no longer in the world of costanza
walls huge
bulgy walls you put it in your back
pocket it messes up your posture it
gives you back pain i mean
frankly speaking who can tolerate a huge
chunk of
crap in their pocket that's where ridge
comes in practically indestructible
sleek wonderful it's got it's it look
it's the future
now it doesn't fold or awkwardly bulge
and it seriously changed the whole
pocket situation
zach tell me about how much you love
ridge and i'm not even putting i don't
mean to put you on the spot but you've
been
you've been raving about it i can't
express to you enough how much i love
this wallet
go on like it's a it's amazing it's game
changer like
it's not just bsing like it really is
sleek and
you know it's not super profound in your
pocket
right it's not super profound in your
pocket look it's
it's it's just genius you got the money
clip yes i am rich how much money i got
here
five and a couple of ones loaded
you got the money clip and then here
they've got this really slick
design i don't want to show my credit
cards like i did last time we had the
blurred out
but the credit cards can you show yeah
you could see it on the back huh
hopefully i didn't show it they just
some internet sleuth is going to decrypt
my card numbers from the back
they just slide in and then there's a
there's a little button here
they pop right out it's like i mean come
on who you kidding
you barely notice it uh most people are
using wallets designed in the 90s
carrying old receipts gift cards hotel
keys give me a break
here are the features that you need to
know about it holds up to 12 cards
plus room for cash there's over 20
colors and styles including carbon fire
and burnt
titanium i like my titanium burnt i
don't know about
you i really love it and don't take my
word for it it's got thirty thousand
five star reviews it's made of durable
material which means each wallet comes
with a lifetime warranty you could buy
this one
wallet and carry it for life the rich
team is so confident
that you'll like it that they'll let you
test drive it for 45 days and you can
send it back for a full refund if you
don't love it
wow that's putting your money where your
mouth is
so we've got an offer for my dudes here
get 10 off today with free worldwide
shipping
and returns by going to ridge.com
h3 that's ridge.com
h3 for 10 off today
so we have uh discussed many important
things yeah we're
i'm going to move on to something even
more important
first of all we have first this hits two
two issues
one being that we discuss bad tattoos it
looks like worms doesn't it
yeah it does not look like beef or ela
what is how does this rate and by the
way
explain what's beef and ched now ched
now
is that a thing no it's like he's saying
like i'm gonna have one now and i'm
gonna have one later because you could
get the two for once
like here now no i don't god no i'm not
i don't know
he doesn't have any tattoos wait wait
wait so who's what i retweeted
wait wait wait did you think this is
explain no but explain the text i
thought it was going to say
for some reason i was looking at him in
chad now what does that mean
oh it means he buys two beers he eats
one now and eats it later oh
dude why because they're always like a
two for one yeah
so you guys do go to arby's a lot no no
do not no
i do not know about the two for one
special because that's him
so tell me about arby's i don't eat at
arby's or go there
he will drag me in there so he can get
something and then you won't even eat
one right there no i don't eat
i don't eat beef wow oh yeah or pork
she's chill
i'm lactose intolerant though so pita
doesn't like meat
but isn't it kind of good you just [ __ ]
it all out another day to be a little
bit cracked
pill but it still is like it's a i wish
that when i eat pizza i just die read it
all out
awesome it's awesome i don't know what's
the problem
my favorite kind of pizza right like
there's like one called mediterranean
and it's like
yeah pesto
it's [ __ ] crazy she doesn't like
pizza yeah i don't like meat or anything
on it so and i
don't care about me i'll eat pretty much
anything yeah
yeah that's my problem yeah i want to
eat it so tell me
you really genuinely love arby's i l
arby's is
i feel the same way about mcdonald's as
i do arby's like it's just another fast
food place i just think that it's arby's
is kind of a meme
like they've got their giant hairstyle
like they're really good at [ __ ] posting
on twitter
have you ever seen someone do that with
a big mac no no i mean there's like
there's a special
there's a culture there's a culture
behind arby's well have you heard about
the meat mountain
i think i have is it like the everything
bring it in
no are you kidding me yeah you actually
did let me tell you the lore
the meat mountain lore oh i'm about as
excited right now
so they sent a box and i was speculating
that they had arby's hats in the box and
when i opened the box and there were
arby's hats i was
incredibly excited and i'm about the
same level excited right now oh
gosh
is it christmas or hanukkah yeah it's
it's both
oh that he loves the horsey sauce
this one's for me yeah now let me give
you a little background on the
on the meat mountain so zach our sound
guy
smaller than i thought it would be he's
a meat boy smaller
by the way i could smell this when we
walked in on the morning like the whole
building smells like arby's meat
mountain
it's just so much meat mountain
so we had to find a sphere it does not
look like that we had to find a special
location
this does not serve that every arby's no
apparently they smoke their 13
their brisket for 13 hours they fooled
me they could have just put diarrhea on
here
so why i don't understand why it has to
be a special arby's because only the
ones that are
trying to make it right right it's a
special
uh that's right it needs special
training and i i should say when zach
came in he
he said when he went and ordered it
today uh when he asked for it they
laughed at him
why they just found their menu why did
they laugh at you they laughed at me
they're like oh man this is gonna hold
up our line
like oh my gosh oh don't sell it
i have a question how much does it cost
uh for two sandwiches it was twenty one
dollars
i don't know that's a lot of calories
that's probably your calories for the
for two days yeah like a human would
need so cheers what's going on with the
collars it's like
tie dye burger it's art it's because the
roast beef is like part of it is gray
and that's what i'm like i just don't
understand
it just looks so repulsive you don't
like gray beef
i don't eat beef i haven't eaten gray
with like a little bit of green and some
really
burgundy also it's going to be all in
his
beard oh put some horsey sauce on that's
the best part yeah
so let me give you the background here
zach
the sound lab was talking about how he
loves darby
sorry what can i do it's just no no
you can continue so
great so we're like
and he loves horsey sauce especially i
do too yeah one
can you crack me open one of those will
you consume one
can we talk about how you're supposed to
open packets how do you open packets
i mean i just crack the [ __ ] i just
crack it i like to
he can if you pinch the corner because
what chelsea does is she'll just like
tear it like that yeah that's where you
out it just gets all over the top right
but you have to so what are you supposed
to do
off this is my strategy if you grab it
kind of like right
where the corner's sticking out a little
bit you can just uh air the corner off
you're too smart look at that you know
it just comes out we've been together
for like
over eight years every single time where
some
he gets he says this to me every single
time i haven't changed my ways
so it's genius but
i don't know that i will do it yeah yeah
because when you're hungry you just
get it open it's like you don't want to
you guys don't want a bite of this no no
i don't eat i don't eat mountains
i don't um
it's so gross oh horsey sauce really
brings it together
oh god this backstory is out
zach was pretty much our garbage
disposal the mac could eat anything
we brought the meat mountains in am
zach what was your experience because i
i was surprised
go ahead zach tell the story well i i
ate it you know and
the whole thing i uh yeah yeah yeah
i ate the whole thing are you kidding me
or did that happen wait when was that
today
no no no no this was uh months ago
yeah yeah so i ate it and it just
killed my [ __ ] stomach yeah like like
i did not [ __ ] right for like a week
yeah i mean even if you like i think any
meat in this quantity would probably you
know what are they called the meat
sweats
yeah yeah right i had that hardcore
there's eight types of meat in it
yeah that sounds about right oh my gosh
you host all the what
i don't support this behavior oh
on the website i noticed it it's going
to be changing to diapers
it's just nutritional info but um if you
go to their nutritional info they don't
actually list it
they're they're hiding it because i want
to know how many calories yeah
yeah i really want to know the calories
i followed them i don't want to know
because i wanted to know and it's
they don't tell it i would guess it's
like five thousand it just like so
basically you just need to look at like
five
or eight sandwiches and add them up wait
meat mountain's not even on here
that's that's what i'm saying it's not
listed
oh well what are you doing obviously
that's that's not great it's the meat
mountain that's a good sign
it destroyed zach zach could not reach
the summit
of meat mountain no this is not a good
use of money
you should spread it out over a couple
beef and cheddars i still love my horsey
sauce though
yeah sauce is the best so i i'm
undefeated
though i will say that i reached the
summit
i looked down i took a diarrhea on it
and i
and i descended last time that you ate
one of these ethan it triggered you went
vegan for a month
you actually you ate one of these before
that's true yeah
literally triggered you to go vegan i
went vegan for a month because of how
bad it is literally this was the last
meet i ate
and now look where i'm right back where
i started putting the bread on this is a
joke like why even bother like it's just
me
it's so high yeah exactly just so that
you're so you don't want to be
less right yeah you don't exactly
see this woman understand something kind
of like putting napkins on top of it
the meat to bread ratios like it's not
the bread is helping you
it does i think you need a shower after
this that's true but
it would be even worse hey does it come
with wet wipes
no no wet wipes yeah this is something
that should come with wet wipes so i've
pretty much eaten like half of this yeah
i'm i've taken a couple bites i just i
know it's gonna happen
if i take too many more bites i'm out
i'm gonna i'm gonna take this with me
though yeah
i'm gonna this might take a couple days
to get through oh my gosh
because i didn't have any smell but i
really don't smell what are you doing oh
my god it doesn't know
dynamite no no no no no there's no way
it fits in a box bro you're like putting
tater tots in your
fanny pack all right
oh you're so stupid you got to send you
to like a petting zoo with the meat
mountain in your pocket or something
tiger king soup all right
did you now speaking you know you know
how the tiger attacked uh
the homeboy what what's his name i
forgot him you mean that
on the show that was confusing because
the whole show they like
refer to her but then you learn after
the fact that
it's he during tiger king
sorry oh the one who got the arm bitten
off
that retirement is safe i was referring
to the main guy
exotic joe when he went in the cage and
he got attacked remember yeah do you
think somebody put something on the shoe
like he
oh like sardine or what was it yeah
sardine oil fish oil because they were
just tired of him and wanted him to get
smacked they wanted him okay i'm gonna
go on a limb is like if you deal with
tigers every day like you're gonna have
an
experience where they just bound to
happen yeah like didn't he claim that
was the only time
ever that like something had happened
like he i think he said something stupid
like that where that was
i don't believe half the stuff that guy
was saying yeah you don't believe joe
exotic
the thing is that show everyone on that
show was guilty
yes except for maybe like a couple of
the the
people that were actual like animal
caretakers or veterinarians who
genuinely were there to just care for
them yeah and even they were still
somewhat complicit because
they knew that these animals were being
abused yeah and they didn't go
do you know do they're like well i gotta
at least help them but it's like i feel
like nobody on that show no one was in
this
no no no no everyone yeah like it's just
you know except netflix
right like it's i mean we watched
everything we watched it over what
a couple days yeah yeah i think i was
ready to watch in a whole day and boy
made me stop
i was like i can't do this all in one
sitting like this i could do it
it was fascinating because this is the
most
like crazy no no this is the crazy thing
yeah
then that homeboy shows up from las
vegas and steals it it's
so weird and it's like how much of it is
you know and the way he treated his
wife you know what i'm saying like you
know how it is like when you're making
content you know like they're trying to
tell a story so it's like who knows
what they're omitting and how they're
like yes of course right
yeah and it builds a stronger picture in
people's heads you know because maybe
somebody was speculating but they just
show the part where they like say it
right
right
you lose the speculation and so you
think they take it more seriously
they're
all crazy and they should all be in jail
can you tell me what tick-tock was
erased of yours
because i only saw this they put it back
it was me
i i made it look like i kicked my cat oh
they're like i'm dancing like walking
with some weird music and then i like
kick and then my cat i replaced them
with a black t-shirt
and then you see me kick the t-shirt and
like it's super it's like the joke where
you put like your hamster
i think filthy frank does you put the
hamster in the sock and then you like
cut and you smash it against the wall
it's like
they got it it's clearly fake yeah well
i'm glad you're restored and justice
was provided took a bit of fighting you
are pretty active on tick tock i don't
really
i feel like a bit of a boomer when it
comes to tick-tock what is going on
there
we they they want more like science
stuff and so they're
they're having us make you're in you're
in touch with tick-tock oh yeah
so we have an obligation to make like 40
tick tocks i'm like halfway done and i
have like a
like a week and a half left to finish
them wow there's like a couple of other
how's it going it's not great i don't
really understand
like it's hard to tell it seems like
you're getting good engagement or maybe
those are just the ones they show
yeah but you don't get to see the behind
the scenes where he's like banging my
head against the wall trying to figure
out because it's like 40
science tickets yeah because they like i
want them to be good and i want them to
like you know
be like interesting or educational but
the problem is like when you sort of try
to make something
educational it takes a lot of work and
yeah everybody watches and then you get
like 40 of them
right and so it's like how do you you
know you have to like demonstrate
something but like
and what sells on tick tock no you're
gonna dance
i could i was thinking she wants why not
that face yeah how do you make dancing
scientists
not young and then a bikini right
i don't i don't have to post educational
ones but then i still have to fulfill
those later yeah so it's like i can
like the cat kicking one is in the
science project so you need to do 40
science yeah
so i've done a bunch that's cool though
that that's that's a nice gig
they're easy to do the ones with the cat
because he's
entertaining and cute it's it's just
like you know with all the other stuff
going on like moving
plus having to make normal videos too
which i've not been doing why don't you
just copy all the other science
ones i could do that but even then like
even they put a lot of work into it
it's not easy to copy oh that's [ __ ]
up like you know buy a bunch of stuff
and like prep it and like
tick tock is trying to get some science
actually i agree that's a i'm impressed
yeah cause i was wondering how does
anyone even make money from this how is
this worth anyone's time i don't think
you do like you have to figure it out
externally
right you know kids are finding success
and then there's
nothing there and they're just like what
do i do right youtube or go somewhere
else i see
i think they have live streaming and
people can pay you they can donate while
you're streaming
oh but i don't know okay
there's a tick tock is interesting
though like at first i wrote it off
completely
but there's actually a lot of weird
strange interesting stuff on there
yeah there's for example a whole genre
of old people
which fascinates me because these are
the type of people that i
assume barely know how to use email yet
they're like lasting
right through tick tock yeah i'm not a
fan of tick tock so
i'm definitely in that yeah i think i
thought it was
not too much social media like i'd
really try to limit
social media i don't need to be on and
then i'm a teacher so every time
if i have anything i just get kids
requesting me over and over so i'd limit
i know oh that's okay she spends like
three to four hours a day on tech talk
like just
yeah that doesn't surprise me it's crazy
it's very popular
it's like psychologically like almost
addicting because you can
like a lot of times what will happen is
someone will send the tick tock and then
when you open the app
it'll open like it'll just load it
differently just goes forever
and then you have to go back and click
the link again and then it'll load the
tic tac they sent you but then you
like once you watch that you sort of
like oh what's the next one and then
you're like oh god you're back in that
the platform is
really it's what you'd say it is watch
and what you skip
and then it curates like a ruler right
so when he was trying to do some like
research on it it was like oh my gosh
what i was like glance i'm like what are
you
looking at and like oh this is tick-tock
i was looking at like 13 year olds i'm
like this looks really fun
honestly man it's it's terrifying this
stuff terrifies me like i have family
friends who have kind of gone down that
rabbit hole a little bit oh
not tick-tock but you can see like the
social media i don't i don't know why
people don't talk more about like the
damage that i think a lot of the social
media causes like
and sort of like recognizing the pattern
like if you find you know someone on
tick-tock who has success you know like
who's attractive
in a bikini like dancing around you go
click on the profile and go all the way
down to the bottom
and look at where they started and sort
of the progression that led them to that
point and what like i have a screenshot
on my phone of this one girl who has
like
you know normal tik-tok normal tic toc
and they each have like a couple hundred
couple thousand views
and there's one with three hundred
thousand views and it's like what do you
think is the difference between them
what is she learning and what's the
feedback that tells you oh
this is what i need to do to get more
engagement at the end of the day like
you get nothing out of it you just feel
like better about yourself because you
have more likes and comments and plays
and stuff but then it's like you do a
normal one and it doesn't do well and
you feel bad about yourself like you're
it's a trap it's literally
and you get nothing and you're setting
yourself up just to feel bad about
yourself and it's just
they all start out normal and it's like
oh dancing or this or that and then it
turns into bikinis and
you know on the beaches i've seen so
many with bikinis lately
and it is it's he showed me because i
was like this is just so
sad and i mean i'm looking at i'm like
these are like little little kids yeah i
don't even go on tick-tock but we got a
couple of requests like because of teddy
fresh sometimes they'll contact us like
hey do you want to send us stuff
like the influencer will wear it and
then i check the
profile and it's like just a girl in
bikini and it's like well she's not even
going to wear it right
right yeah she's going to like make a
little hat
well i yeah all the really popular
people
like i i scroll the instagram discover
page
which i find interesting because there's
all this weird
like [ __ ] weird [ __ ] dude like
turkish
chefs really it's awesome [ __ ] freaking
stuff no like these crazy like guy fieri
of turkey like
they take uh they take like ball sacks
of sheep and stuff it with rice bro
really and it just looks so [ __ ] up
but they love it they eat that [ __ ] man
like are they creating it just for like
this no they love it
but there's a lot of good content is
what i mean to say but every once in a
while
the tick the really popular tick tocks
will bleed into my discover page and
that's how i know the really popular
ones like they're stolen and reposted
but they're like uh the really popular
tick talkers are getting like 50 million
views
yeah per [ __ ] dance video yeah
and they're and a lot of them are like
not even 18. yeah
oh no and as a teacher the kids that's
like the big
so before it was called tick tock it was
called something else
right so it's like a video i can't do
you see the but
yeah tick tock they were bought out by
so you know they're owned by
china yeah it's [ __ ] crazy can't
think of it oh it'll come to me oh
musically that's what it was
oh it was musically yeah oh yeah i don't
even know how it works they sync
the singing it's yes you can open you
can record in the app and you can have
a song play while you record and so you
can like record and then do the thing
or you could while listening to the
audio as it's playing in the recording
if that makes any sense it's
automatically synchronized
and then uh you can like trim it and
post it and it could be songs movie
clips tv shows because
a lot of people would you know mimic
scenes that they liked and you know
popular scenes right
or you can add the music in after the
fact i wish i had that but the kids
would love it
yeah i don't i love it though i mean
fifth graders
that is the cool thing is to make tick
tock so i remember
just like all the little dances on there
and they would like want to come in
before school
and if we were having fun friday they're
just tick-tocking they were filming
and filming and filming and filming and
it's
kids would go oh yeah mine got taken
down someone reported me i just made a
new one isn't it or what is it just
whatever
i think people can report you for a lot
of things maybe probably like cyber
bullying things like that but also
inappropriate like you're too young
my friend nigel has is doing the same
thing too he's making 40 of them and i
always ask him because he's a chemist
and i always ask him to make math
because i know he knows how to do it and
i left that comment on the tick tock
gone your comment goes my comment gone i
said next next
project can you show us how to make math
and they j it was just wiped like no
report or anything i just couldn't see
the comment there interesting
like china doesn't [ __ ] around uh-uh
those [ __ ] know how to censor
like that comment would have lived
anywhere like on youtube oh yeah or
twitter anything
like it wasn't that i mean it's stupid
but it's not like bad and so i was very
surprised i'm impressed with their
how good they are at censoring yeah it
just yeah so that's the but the kids
though
they get deleted and they just make a
new account yeah it kind of scares me
that the kids are
using this like platform that blasts
them out publicly did you see the
video the live stream of the kid putting
his cat in the microwave he actually did
that didn't microwave the cat but like
he put his cat in the microwave he's on
he was like on twitch the account's like
deleted immediately
um but he like puts the cat in the
microwave and he's like you can see him
looking at the phone at like the twitch
chat and then he like you know he's just
joking but he's like maybe eight and
then he like puts his phone in the
microwave and runs the thing and then
you just see the screen go like
i don't know if that was fake because i
think that the microwave should have
blocked the phone's reception so i don't
really know
but he just it looks kind of real i
don't know well if you microwave a phone
there would be some kind of reaction
though
yeah it would it would fry the phone
yeah but it would also
it would also like uh the microwave uses
the same
frequency as your phone kind of like the
2.4 gigahertz
the reason we try it well yeah i mean
your phone basically will stop
it won't work unless you're the cell
network might work so if he was on the
cell network i don't know exactly but
like
this is like fun facts like the reason
wi-fi is because of wi-fi like the
frequency it's on
is because of microwaves but what does
that have to do with microwaving a phone
because the microwave if you're on wi-fi
it's commonly 2.4 gigahertz
and so a microwave is 2.4 gigahertz like
the frequency on the inside and so
when you put the phone in there the
microwave is designed to keep that
radiation
inside of the microwave like that's what
like the little mesh screen on the front
is for
um and so if the phone is on a 2.4
gigahertz wi-fi
it shouldn't be able to like escape the
microwave like it'll just block the
wi-fi connection so the phone shouldn't
fry
no the phone will still fry nobody was
but the live streams he was calling
live oh it was live stream so the phone
and the microwave right oh that's kind
of interesting i mean
there's probably you know there's other
stuff too so it could have cell network
or like the 5.8 gigahertz that's a good
experiment
yeah for an eight-year-old but that's
but i'm just saying like in general like
you see this kid on twitch who's
you know like a kid and then he's like
the chat is like
do the thing don't do the thing and then
he's like oh i can have an audience
people are watching me
that's put my phone in the microwave put
my cat like he literally puts his cat in
the microwave that's horrific
like but i don't know i'm very worried
we have a one-year-old son
and we grew up i mean we're a little bit
apart
yeah but i think close enough i never
saw
even a smartphone until like my last
year of college
right smartphones didn't even exist and
so
that wasn't part of my upbringing at all
but theodore came out in high school for
us
yeah i didn't i didn't have anything
until i think
after college or maybe the end of
college i just never bought it
yeah we were also really like last
people to buy it you know in our
room i was like whatever [ __ ]
like the friends i had it's like oh my
gosh don't click on the internet we
bought
some really uh we bought like knockoff
phones from china
yeah for like 200 a pop back then we
recently yeah
no no no no no that was our first one
that's awesome
i had i think i was like a flip well i
had the nokia back and i'd like to share
with my brother
and all that you know just but yeah
they're
i mean it's just it's i don't even know
how to relate
to theodore it really scares me because
i
personally have so many problems with
social media like it affects
me as an adult so it's bad what is it
going to be like for him and what am i
supposed to do as a parent
you know like how can you even avoid you
can't avoid it
and i don't even know what to tell him
but just like i think you just got to
make sure that
you got to educate and you have to you
can't tell me what to do
don't give free reign don't give free
writing restrictions and limitations
there has to be like
if you get these things done you can get
time if you didn't get it done you go to
your responsibilities you don't know
i have so many parents like i can't i
don't know how to get them off the phone
or off
take it away i think they need to have
better tools
that like respect bandwidth so it's not
necessarily blocking sites it just makes
it so like
it's very slow what's up because you
don't have to fight and struggle with
the phone because if the kid's like i
got to do my homework it's like okay
cool you have
basically dial up speed so like you can
do the thing you need to do but you
can't watch a video you can't
that's what's up like that and then have
it if you really want to
buffer a youtube video you can let it
sit for you know an hour
and i think also the big thing is just
being involved and like talking about it
yeah
don't just let them isolate in their
rooms like talk about oh what are you
watching what's funny like and you talk
to them about it and make it so you're
not like
oh kids i can't keep up with you and
it's just so i can't i'm not gonna
say no you need to stay you need to stay
involved you need to know what's
relevant
i watch shows that i hear the kids like
talking about so that i know
like i remember when you know 13 reasons
why i came out or
riverdale i watched them so i knew what
they were talking i know for a fact that
they just do stuff underneath that you
have like
no it's impossible to catch all this
stuff but don't
think don't like bury your head in this
yeah yeah i think my
only strategy really is just to
stay involved you have to give them as
much
self-confidence and self-worth as you
can as a parent
and talk and hopefully all the time when
they come home and if they say like what
did you do at school nothing
like don't give me that you're going to
talk to me or you don't get to go do you
want to play war zone
then
you have to teach those skills too
because that's another thing is like
it's harder
to have conversations and to be able to
actually like engage like this
the attention span is just gone so
have conversations i'm taking notes
it's super important i mean but parents
everyone's busy so it's hard but trying
to
to sit down and have dinner together
that's a huge impact positive impact and
talking about
and them hearing about your day too i
mean don't tell them about like scary
things like
bills and stuff like that i can speak so
that was not good as a kid to hear that
but
just you need to be a real person and
not just like oh it's just mom and dad
and i think people use it to babysit too
so it's almost like it becomes
convenient for parents
and there has to be limitations you
can't have the phone all day
you don't need your xbox all day you
don't need your computer all day
i think that xbox is probably better
than social media though but still needs
to be limitations you shouldn't
do six hours of gaming i feel like i
think media has a deeper education
than just being a gamer dude i use the
game for like 15 hours a day that's epic
never questions being on instagram
15 hours yeah we play outside we play
you know i did that neighbors i did all
that do you have all right
leave me alone mom i'll be honest with
you looking back
even now i don't even like regret
that time those were magical beautiful
memories yeah and i forged online with
my friends
i wouldn't have had the attention span
to do something for 15 hours straight
okay
you're not a gamer yeah when i when i
play games when i do my gamer thing it's
like it's with
friends yeah you're like talking online
like i won't you're like coordinating
you're playing it's about teamwork we're
going rank camaraderie
we're okay a portion of your day but you
don't get to do that for the majority of
you you're not even my mom
you have no authority right what are you
planning anything right now
so okay i grew up where he was not
allowed to play video games not allowed
to watch tv
not only look how it turned out yeah it
didn't work it didn't work
so he was definitely i've played like
250 war zone games
what the [ __ ] is duty warzone is a
first-person shooter
like fortnite it's like any of the other
ones it's like the same
see i used to be hardcore into
counter-strike
and yeah and team fortress classic but i
lost interest and first-person shooters
because i can't compete with all these
little [ __ ] 13 year olds with the
influx of like right now but no i wasn't
playing those like expect what i'm
saying i played like 250 games
just the other day i won a game your
first game yeah but it's like and it was
amazing
like i don't yeah
oh my yeah i was asleep and it was like
what's wrong is it
it wasn't like a happy scream it was a
terrorist
scream but like that's okay because it's
congratulations thank you
thank you a lot i appreciate what you've
done
some don't but i do i don't really care
well because he has to edit
he has to film and we have other things
responsibilities that he's ignoring to
play no
but god let the man let me finish my
thought
you know it's not about the destination
right it's about the journey and then
that's what it's about yeah and to
answer your question you said what am i
playing yeah
oh we this is weird but i'm like
so deep into diablo 3. really i started
playing double three when it came out
and i played the [ __ ] out of it
and now it's like the game is like dead
dead
dead and they have different seasons
where you try to
you a character restarts at that
beginning of every new season and then
your character just disappears forever
so i've been grinding deep boy yeah this
season
and i'm like number 200 in the world
number two because i always tell them
because there's only like 200 players it
sounds like no they're
well no there's like there's thousands
okay i'm number 200 in the world
a fighting game is it give him a dungeon
okay cool i don't know what this game is
but what do you do
do you do puzzles it's a dungeon crawler
elaborate so i play i can't
have the conversation no there's no
dragon consumer okay let me put it you
got to start
let me put it this way explain why i am
a [ __ ]
demon hunter if you don't know what a
demon hunter is i'm a badass mother
with a but with projectile weapons that
goes into the depths of hell
to hunt down the demons that are
invading this
storyline who cares
and they level up what i do is they sit
for hours every night when they're on
stream
no no no there's the excitement is gone
it's really just my time to relax
everyone's asleep relax and they stay
out all night and then yeah i can't can
i just talk about my hobby
so all the lights are off and everyone's
sleeping
and i'm just sitting there and you play
the same dungeon like
i've run through the same dungeon like
probably ten thousand times
what's your actions is that a metric in
diablo no it's not but it's probably
like five
what's your paragon level paragon level
is 1200
that's a real thing okay dude i'm level
1200
wow is that a lot it's all right
dan doesn't know dan has a professional
diablo iii player what did he say when
you thought about my project
he actually said he was impressed
[Music]
for a boomer you know i had a friend in
high school
in the world before him yeah he had a
bunch of zoomer bots like he had a bunch
of
licenses that he got somehow i don't
really know i i don't remember it being
completely legit or he bought them on
some weird marketplace
and he was running like 10 copies of
diablo on his computer
and it was all it was like he was
farming stuff and selling it yeah back
in the day they had an auction house it
ruined the whole [ __ ] game yeah yeah
they had an auction house
you would sell items for real money yeah
it was just it was just
horrible yeah well he he helped with
well he he
uh your friend made some real money too
that he ended up selling the whole like
botting kit to somebody for like a
reasonable for a kid in high school like
that's awesome
under a couple thousand dollars yeah
that was pretty epic but
it's like the new bitcoin first gator
that's my gaming that's pretty gamer
what's the longest you played in out in
one city oh probably less than an hour
it's not very gamer i just don't have
the attention span like
i can sit and read a book for an entire
day but like
so who says that's better than gaming
yeah no seriously
yeah you know back before video games
existed people would sit there all day
on the books and they would be like
you don't don't read all day go play
with a stick
the same it had the same exact
connotation but as a kid i had a
i just had a hard time doing anything
for too long i guess an adult i can read
as a kid i couldn't read all you read
fiction or non-fiction
both you would really waste your time
reading
history i read books it's not very
productive i love historical fiction
oh it's so good i love you but i as a
kid i just couldn't
do anything for more than an hour were
there pictures in the books
no do you color inside or no coloring
i tried to buy him some books that i
thought he would pay money for these
a lot of money i said a lot of money on
books every year and i don't know
expensive they are then they put them on
the kindle and you'd expect them to be
cheaper but they're not
they're not and i can't do the kindle it
just it doesn't work for me i like it
it doesn't feel the same i really can't
get
past you close to video games no it's
not i think it might be racist
i like seeing how far i am but i like
the feel of it i like the smell of books
i'm yeah
what's your favorite book ever my
favorite series is harry potter series
like
if i had to pick a book how do you feel
about her being uh
chelsea probably has no idea are you
aware that what's your name
oh you are okay what's the what's her
name yeah jk
smoking my bowling yeah so stupid
there is actually well we have a better
thing no we have faith
that's not better that's very rude
um are you aware that she does not like
trans people i
am aware so i've seen a bunch of stuff
recently
um actually i don't know yeah she she
basically made a comment statement that
was
really really stupid can you pull up the
can you pull that up let's look over it
yeah let's dig into this hasn't really
done much to kind of
rectify the situation and then all the
cast members of course are like
we want nothing to do with this
statement we do not agree we do not
you know so that's been interesting that
i was shocked that she didn't come out
immediately and try to
you know actually she doubled down i
think she really believed it
but i mean i mean i thought she was
going to do the opposite
and instead she just came out saying no
you guys are understanding this is the
guy by the way
sorry the turkish yeah oh yeah it's the
legend
what the [ __ ] this video we got after a
while
no this is this guy's like mega famous
and he just goes like all out
i'm trying to find a go this is just
tick tock i've never watched them on
tick tock
i don't think it's as good as as on
instagram because it's shorter
yeah that's a lot of views no this guy
is like yeah he's famous these these
videos are not as good
because he's 14 million wow okay let's
let's have a look
you're just looking at the thumbnails i
could tell they put the epic thing in
the thumbnail
i have not let's see you never know
where it's going with this i saw the
ladybug
pizza oven looking thing yay
he's called czn which is kind of kind of
bizarre
yeah in the best way look look how
creepily he's staring
he that's his thing but you can't like
how does he do it that's his thing and
sometimes people will not be smiling and
then everyone's like is he okay
you're putting vegetables and chops his
finger
so do you think he does all this work or
in between the cuts you just got all
these
minions coming into it because what are
you doing it looks like he's doing it i
think
why epic that was a lot of fire whoa did
you see that spin move with the knife it
was epic that was dangerous yeah where's
he putting the meat in this it's just a
big ass
uh lamb leg it looks like you put it in
sand that was kind of gross
that's one of the techniques they use no
they use these
but they do use sand no but it looks
like you stuck the meat directly on
they do that but it's not sand it's like
some kind of material that like uh
oh yeah i don't know man they do all
kinds of weird [ __ ] in turkish cuisine
bro
tick-tock is weird this i don't like his
tick-tock you gotta go to
instagram well is there not mute is
there music normal yeah there's
it's just very like yeah a lot of times
though but again i don't have the right
i'm i'm not the person to ask because i
don't did you i really limit social
media because of like what you said like
the negativity
that i saw growing up i was like i don't
want to be that kind of
person that's so obsessed so i really
limit social media i think sometimes i
take a break and i really feel better i
think i can do for one
yeah like a cabin trip
where we have a metal box and everyone
sticks their phone in it like oh my god
we should do that you have like a nokia
like an old nokia that just has like
calls and texts
yeah that's like the phone that if you
need to call somebody for like
yeah yeah yeah i do i set a limit for
like 20 minutes for
all social media combined a day i feel
like really
and because that's the problem right yes
and then i realized it's just such a bad
how you get your phone and you click on
it without even thinking
yes and it's like any any moment any
moment where you have nothing to do it's
like you're just
yeah like what am i always like yeah and
it's definitely a problem sometimes i'll
close it
and then without thinking i open it
again uh-huh yeah always
yeah can i say it creeps me out can i
admit something yeah when bo
uh burnham was on the show he said that
he started
p i'm just i can't look away from czn
he's making a giant dude though like
that's the
look he's cutting the hammer with a
[ __ ] sword bro
you can't even eat that no he throws it
all out afterwards as we are
just like eating the meat so bo said
that he start he was so bad that he was
peeing down
peeing down sitting down to pee so he
could use his phone
and i was like that's weird and then but
i do that now
just because you can like more easily
use the phone because i can continue
what i'm doing
right so i sit down and tinkle and i've
always been so envious that
like men could stand up there you go
cause i'm like i have to
you have to worry about all the extra
throwing away guys
well to be honest yeah my penis
privilege privilege to be able to
yeah because thinking about going to
like a fair and using a porta potty
you want me to squat either wants to
like pin my penis back and make me squat
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah she's sick
garbage garbage
well um how much have you spent on
roombas
oh we spent um
actually it's kind of funny because i
bought i ended up buying an actual
roomba too
um i think i spent about the same amount
of money on the actual room
as i did on eight knockoff rooms
or whatever so that was like a thousand
dollars i think oh that's not bad for
eight rooms
they came in the course of like probably
two or three days and it was just like
all these yeah it was it was paid for
it's a whole long story but i didn't
even pay for it someone else paid for it
but that's like it's i don't even think
i'm supposed to say what happened
yeah no i don't think you're allowed to
go ahead no i can't well
i'll tell you after it's a whole lot he
got paid yeah but anyway somebody else
paid for him
okay yeah but he did buy an actual
roomba and he
you don't like it he doesn't he yells at
it all the time
dude it was like i bought someone gave
me a coupon so i bought it much cheaper
and uh it's still like it's very
frustrating for how much money it costs
brand new it's like the nicest one they
sell that like self-empties and
everything and it's like how does it
not how is it not a little bit smarter
than it is it'll just run over
everything this will just get bound up
on carpet really yeah and i think
wires like if you have like nick plugs
and stuff it'll just
get caught up in that yeah i've heard
good things about the room but what year
is it what edition
bran is the nicest one that i sell right
now that's a shame
i don't like the look of it it's sort of
like one of those things where you know
you can't have any cables on the floor
you can't have anything
i mean i don't really love the idea of a
little robot skirting around the house
yeah yeah so tell actually tell them why
you
your first um your beginning
relationship with roomba
when did you first get a roomba for your
mother i bought one off of an old
website
remember woot they sold one thing a day
oh i think i had to like clean was it
like my chore was vacuuming and so i
saved up like a couple hundred bucks and
bought a roomba for like it was like 150
maybe two was she satisfied with the
result of that i think she was
angry but maybe also impressed yeah am i
a genius
and she used it i mean she had that for
a long time probably 10 years
wow recently died yeah i had to change
the batteries a bunch because they just
kept yeah
anytime that maintenance needed to be
done on it it was like even when
he hadn't lived there for years william
he's acting up
you need to come over and figure it out
he's like yes but the new ones they
dock themselves they charge them
themselves too
i don't like it though i like that
there's two vacuums there's one in the
base station and there's one in the road
so the robot does its factory you have
to empty the base
yeah it comes with like a bag and the
bag will last you like so many you have
to empty something yeah i don't want to
empty anything
it's not self-emptying if i have to
empty it i think there's one i want a
[ __ ]
i want a well that okay if you want to
learn about vacuums
there's this dude every time i search
yourself there's this guy on youtube who
does
nothing but make videos about vacuum
cleaners and it is it is hilarious
just because of like the content the
content
but he's so serious and it's actually
like if it is the best resource
so did you use this resource before you
purchased the rumba
i did but he steered you wrong clearly
no
i think that there's just like there's
not a whole lot of perfect solutions
right now you just think for the amount
of money you spend on it that like it
would be a little bit bigger but we have
like the other vacuum we have it's a you
know
it's i think it's like a shark or
something it's a handheld one uh the
handheld one
i mean it just works so much better i
love the handheld bra
it's like the greatest wait the the
cordless vacuum yeah yeah
dude those are fun you remember and it
takes me no time
to drag this big ass vacuum around yeah
like a hundred feet
yeah and my dad bought
because we have a cat so i just like
don't like hair i just don't want people
you know so but it takes no time it's so
easy
and it makes this cool sound it goes um
yeah you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
the crusher
it's not bad and either no how good they
have no
social media cordless vacuum cleaners
ungrateful i remember i
remember the nightmares because we
didn't have enough like power outlets
around yeah
so there were parts that you just
couldn't and we had stairs growing up
there were carpeted stairs bring me that
meat mountain back
oh my gosh no i threw it away no i don't
want that [ __ ] out of your pocket bro
i just got corona and everything else
are you what are you gonna do with that
sandwich you're gonna eat it
oh he will yeah he's disgusting so just
bring it up
william has the no william has a meat
mountain and is
well you could get it out of the garbage
no i'm kidding i'm kidding
i'm not really kidding right i am i'm
kidding what do you get out of the
carpet
i don't think the meat out of my pocket
throw
[Laughter]
so so what's more sanitary the meat in
william's pocket or the trash can
well i think i'm mistaken i i don't
think i did throw it away i see the bag
over there so if you bring it on it
probably that you guys
i'm sorry i need to cause he's gonna
walk out he will see it
then that that's a white lie you could
have lied here i give you it's my
birthday
oh is it yes william's birthday was like
two weeks ago how old are you
40. bro come on don't play me like that
bring me that mountain how old do you
think william just turned i think he
told me he's like 28.
yeah 29 20. yeah yeah i feel old now
get it out that hair
i was protected by a plastic bag
please don't please don't eat it
what are you gonna do for me what are
you gonna do okay what do you want
your laptop is glistening i know i know
i saw that well hold on dan we're
negotiating what are you gonna do for me
we can order a pizza there you go that's
all i want to do
oh cause you hate pizza wait wait i
don't hate it
he wants it every night oh okay i see so
[ __ ]
how dare you okay so for a while but
does he get it every day
like you might want it yeah for a while
william wanted to eat
in and out like every day and i'm like
you just can't eat the same thing every
day that's like that and that's so good
i didn't hate pizza i was a normal
person yeah but
i would eat it like
like social events or a birthday party
yeah that's when i would eat pizza it
sort of is like
more of an appetizer than a with ethan
it's like all the time so we are doing a
pizza tonight right
that's just how many how many days a
week do you even
buy it's just not true do you have that
one uh
zach i don't think i don't think we have
enough yeah
you start really going at it on twitter
yeah
the comment well so the comments on
keemstar's because he blocks so many
people
it's just a bunch of dick writers on his
right which is just so he's such a
coward little
i'm just kidding i'm not going to get
all worked up about him but like all the
comments are just like please stop
yeah yeah and then he blocks them all
you have to unders but um
i feel like i only react yeah when he
says [ __ ] then i
then like for the longest time i just
let him say whatever he wants
but now i i'm just i'm reacting to
everything right
and i think it's great i mean it's
entertaining
i mean i'm really proud of this one from
last night which i have to say is going
really well for me
what happened before the one about two
jackasses
i can tell that one really upset him
because he's like this morning he's
going
off he made a poll that said should i
keep bullying h3 yes or no
oh like bowling bro you're like [ __ ]
40. garbage
carpet so anyway i think this one really
um
this one really upset him because it did
so well
but he what's the i don't really
understand he thinks that
this is really you're gonna be so dumb
he thinks that ila
there's this thing that all really rude
people say that eel looks like a horse
okay
very rude and so keemstar thinks it's
funny
no she's very beautiful and doesn't look
like a horse well and especially for
like a man to be like commenting right
like crazy
so crazy yeah and so he's tweeted at me
literally a hundred times
but he thinks he's so slick because he
just tweets pictures of a horse without
saying what it is
so it's like certain people know what
he's saying and certain people
don't they'll just be like oh what beard
is immaculate though
yeah diet sunglasses look like something
my grandmother would wear
that's true he's got like the kind of
vintage
but he goes it's a donkey and he says is
this a horse h3 and i said all i see is
two jackasses that's pretty good
right that's a good response thank you
it really upset him how old is he he's
like 40.
oh wait go to the comments i want to see
all the people pleading no i don't
i don't because because look as long as
this guy
his whole timeline is full of [ __ ] about
me
like let's go over here and just have a
look that's that's all he has time for
in his life by the way
this horse you know what he was doing he
was at a petting zoo with his
daughter and he had made time to tweet
at me like five times
he was at a petting zoo with his
daughter a lot of real estate
in his mind i'm just amused by it and
he's so upset
you are a piece of [ __ ] gum come on
keemstar give it a rest
[ __ ] hypocrite here he sent me a dm
didn't he get banned from youtube at
what point one point a while back
yes yeah yeah and they like
circumnavigated that somehow so there's
one there's
two so there's the oh my god here's me
hey ethan want to play minecraft with me
he retweeted his own tweet
because he thought it was good and it's
good he does that sometimes
he says this one he said which thumbnail
should i use he said this one
that's a nice picture though yeah that's
cool i like the horse with the hat
that's kind of cute
yeah um
yeah i'm on his mind a lot yeah oh then
this one at the petting zoo he goes
he goes to the sunset with my daughter
here trying to enjoy time with my
daughter reminds me of something
and then and then he posted this
oh jesus that's at least took some
yeah so i'm glad that i'm on his mind
more than his own [ __ ] daughter
apparently that's really really oh but
that's just the tip of the iceberg
so i don't understand and he's too old
to be acting that way
talk to keemstar as a teacher you spend
a lot of time with children talk to him
i
do and children pick up on everything
that their parents do and say like
they're a [ __ ] hipper
they do they do they really do this is a
lot of like negativity
like uh a lot there's so many like
channels on youtube that really really
like
capitalize on like other people's
problems yeah stuff and it's like
it kind of makes me sad a little bit you
know like there's there's it's like oh
look at someone's down
like now is my time to like speed up
fine and yeah
exactly and and like like that's fine
garbage but the problem is like
when your paycheck is attached to it
then it's like who am i
right exactly that's like you're allowed
to be an ass to people like i don't care
but the problem becomes when it becomes
your income it's like now i have to be
an ass and i'm gonna like seek out
the the easiest targets for me to take
down absolutely because i profit off of
it and it's like
then you end up with that kind of broken
loop where you're learning
yeah to pick on people absolutely like
but here's the thing is like
um i ignore like 70
of it and i respond to like the 30 which
i think is funny
right because at this point the thing
about keemstar is
that he's very dangerous because he is
relentless
and and he will just he's very
vindictive
and he'll just say and do anything too
a little game for him like every time
you look at his twitter every week it's
someone else
he's i think he's like cross line but
being on the receiving end it's so
damaging and it's
i mean even like it really can drive you
crazy and i'm not yeah
the thing is like the thing is he he was
always bringing up these new crazies
things about me like that i'm stealing
money or that
someone said this about and just making
[ __ ] up lying doing everything
and then he's at the point where he
literally exhausted everything
to the point where he's going back in my
old tweets and finding pictures of me
with mud on my face from the dead sea
in israel and saying i'm doing blackface
right but
but so it's like he's spending a lot of
time digging into your
person he's he's also weaponizing
his following right with every tweet
he's showing them
like send me send me more you know but
um
but yeah it's not a great thing to live
your life he's dangerous and he's very
and i think he's very damaging
to the to the community as a whole even
even like
um like there's no there's no real
rebuttal for an accusation
even if you completely prove any
innocence or anything like people will
always have that in their head
a lot of people might not even see that
yeah because the rebuttal is not yes
like who miranda sings
some stuff yeah and like it sounded bad
from the outside and i started watching
it
what the big hype was it was just kind
of like an awkward relationship
so this dude made this video exposing
her and he and he's like oh she sent me
lingerie
when i was a kid and i was like
oh man he totally [ __ ] her right
because i
i've like you know but when we do stuff
like i'll just send crap to people like
i've literally sent like a piece of
plywood in the mail to someone
that's what she was doing yeah it was
like part of a stream and it wasn't used
or
right which is such a big difference
yeah it was something because he said i
was
he said i never even touched it or
opened it from the back like is it right
this was something that was used
and it's gross and i think he'd even
like asked for it or wanted it
yeah so like not saying that that was
the smartest thing she could have done
but like right
my thoughts but before that like having
heard it was much worse than after the
fact and like how many people
and that's what that's what he does like
he put out a video
which was kind of one of the motivating
factors for me making my my initial
videos i don't know how much you
followed this probably not
no yeah good for you yeah you're better
off i was teaching online
yeah that's probably it's very way less
yeah
better use of your time so he puts out
that um
that i that i'm stealing money
from a collab we did with a video game
company
that i was supposed to donate to charity
and i go
i get the guy on the phone and i say
uh he's like that's not true and that
video's still up
and people still believe it yeah yeah
and i don't think that somebody who's
willing to just
lie to that capacity everyone who
presents themselves as news
is is is a real danger
or like look into any of this so it's
like i'm assuming he wouldn't be invited
to like
it's complicated because i think you
know like the instant youtube starts
like pushing buttons behind the scenes i
mean people lose their mind thinking
that you're
convincing them yeah they took a picture
with susan like two years which to me is
comical because like they don't give up
don't fight they don't care they think i
have susan on speed though no
only lately like in the past week or two
i'm starting to understand
also that this is kind of um
dipping into anti-semitism too because
all of a sudden i'm getting all these
racist comments on my stuff
and then it's like when you connect the
dots they're saying that ethan is greedy
he's always about the money and now he's
running
a conspiracy behind the scenes with the
ceo of youtube like that's
yeah and well if you say that people
will take it wrong but
keemstar literally tweeted it but we'll
take it people please keemstar tweeted
out like two days ago ethan is the
george soros of youtube
right i mean that is an anti-semitic uh
conspiracy
also i want to raise if you've got
george soros money
he's like a multi-billionaire right i
don't know anything about him
i just i wish youtube was more like the
early early days when everybody was like
there was less money involved people
were more like creative like we want to
be filmmakers they saw tv and they're
like oh we want to do skits and special
effects and comedy and blah blah blah
and like that's like when i make you
know made youtube videos early on like
you know we'd watch like quarter digital
freddie w
um shay carl who's sort of like has
fallen from grace's
in the past couple years um cassim g you
know like all of these genres that are
just like having fun
and like doing skits and like making
content and it seems like now there's
this huge huge huge population of
content that's just like
what's something that we can [ __ ] on
it's meta content yeah not real
exactly yeah and like some of it is more
like you know like criticisms of pop
culture and i think that stuff is fine
but then you get like the real dark
stuff where it's like
attacks on people's personalities and a
lot of this stuff ends up being like
speculation
um i mean even like the whole thing with
with idubbbz ian where you're just like
what is going on
like it was just it was purely
entertainment for people like nobody
actually cares it was it was like a
britney spears moment where they're like
let's just
go all in and like watch this spectacle
unfold insane
it was so yeah i felt bad for how how
everyone just was like
who gives a [ __ ] if it doesn't
affect anything right but i think
they're honestly i think
another problem is that there's like a
really
large i think there's some kind of
weird political movement online where
it's like the
people who walk around saying [ __ ] that
actually uh
think that's funny people who say uh
cuck and soyboy
unironically there's a lot of people
right on youtube
and they're the people that think that
uh idubbbz
is a [ __ ] right and they think that that
is an actual insult
that's a better word i didn't know what
that meant like the the actually
well because that was like the main
acquisition was simp right and it didn't
even matter
simp doesn't make sense at all because
he's people he's getting it
yeah the simplest one who pays and
doesn't get it right he doesn't pay
and just like the whole thing was just
like let's light something on fire
but [ __ ] also i guess cuck does make
more sense even though
but not really it still doesn't and it
doesn't really make any sense either
yeah neither of those labels work yeah
yeah it's a very it's very strange and i
i don't know like some days for when
things go on
you've never had anything like severe
but why don't i just
can't imagine having to like
live in that fear of like oh my gosh
this per like he did nothing
and then all this happened for no choice
a lot of people forget that you're like
a real person yeah he
made no choices it was his you know had
nothing to do with i've been feeling
like that for
years yeah dude like meeting ian for the
first time
he's like a drastically different person
than you would think yeah i think the
problem is like the audience sort of
like has
you know like he's an edge lord he's one
of them when you're like making a graph
in science you call it like
extrapolation
where it's like you have these two
points of like what you think is going
on like what you know is going on and
then you just sort of go beyond that and
that's what people have done say like
they sort of see this thing that ian is
and they sort of just assume
outside of what they've seen like who he
is as a person
yeah and and then when he does something
that sort of counters that or maybe you
know maybe he like changes or learned
something new or had
a debate with somebody where he you know
realized maybe he was thinking about
something wrong
and then he changed his opinions and now
all of a sudden everybody is like
like freaking out he's not like us yeah
i think the same thing happened to me is
that
like back in the day we were doing all
these like it was really
making fun of social justice warriors
was like the fun thing to do
there was so much good content and they
were so fun to make fun of and it's not
necessarily
a partisan thing but it did court a lot
of very
conservative edge lords who actually
hate women right
and are actually i would say um
toxically conservative right i mean not
i'm not
i'm not that's not a critique of like
conservatism it's more like people who
are like in cells
and hate women and things people who are
who have our sex workers are like
immoral stuff like that
yeah and so i courted a lot of these
people and i think that's a lot of
people who are angry at me today
is because i think i did make a
conscious effort throughout the past
several years to
kind of make it very clear that um
i do not share the same values as these
people yeah
you know right and when you're making
content though it's like it's just
sometimes hard like you're trying to be
entertaining and sometimes poking
buttons and like poking and stuff like
that
is entertaining and then people take it
too seriously
like it's all it's like consumed
literally like this is this is exactly
what you think like this is not a joke
and then you start like filling in the
outside of like you know coloring
outside the lines of who that person is
and it just i don't know they don't
realize like at the end of the day like
i
have problems too and like i struggle
with and their stuff
like yeah exactly like i don't
understand half the stuff i do and how
people interpret it i'm just like all
right i'm going to try to be creative
today and see what happens yeah you know
and
that's like well you know i think the
original like early on when like
the first podcaster people are all upset
like to me it's like i see that it's the
same thing it's like a content
production thing it's like we're making
content what do people want to see
yeah you make a decision and at the end
of the day people treat it as like some
malicious attack where like your intents
were to do a bad thing
and it's like just making stuff for
people to consume and sometimes
well people have no idea what goes on
behind the scenes no idea what it
what goes into editing no idea what goes
and just took
making a video people think you just
turn on your camera
you press record you press stop you
upload it to youtube like that's it and
it's like there's so much more and
that is not well known or
really spoken about and so then the
people just demand demand to man-to-man
and they think that they can just get
everything like that that's that's
absolutely not the reality of being a
youtuber it's
i remember when he started it like i had
no idea and the amount of hours that he
puts into things and
how he works way way
more than i do and i have a full-time
job and he wakes
he works way more than me he doesn't
take breaks i can barely get him to take
like a weekend day off for a good
you know let alone if my let's go on a
vacation it's my spring break and he's
just like i have to
it's no one knows that yeah and that
you're gonna be asked for a really long
time until we made a conscious
decision like we gotta start taking
weekends off or
yeah we don't work on weekends now yeah
well we
we always work still like it's not the
same though
i was like i'm filming today the weekend
is off now was it easier for you to
did you do that before you had your son
or did you guys do that
you know as that like transition i think
there was a time when we were like going
super hard on the grind
and that means like non-stop so we're
working working working and then we
started to just feel bad all the time
and it just got unhealthy and it's easy
for me to come and say like honey you
need to take
the we're going to take this week we're
going to do this or we're going to go
here i'm going to book this and you
don't have to say
because i i'm not in it the same way as
he is like yes i'm close to it i
understand
but i have a normal you know quote
normal job and structure and all this
stuff and
he doesn't so that's you know it's a
battle and i'm
always trying to i think he's more
receptive now the longer he's been in it
yeah i feel like i've been like
recognizing like issues for a while now
like trying to better separate because
it's like i have such a hard time
separating the two words like well i
have a thing to do
and i have to finish it by this date so
i might as well work on it on saturday
because otherwise it's gonna be more
difficult for me to do it on monday and
then it's like
you know who makes who makes the rules
like i make the rules because i'm the
one who decides when
to do stuff or not it's like you do make
the rules but you also
don't sometimes it feels like because if
something is
moving and you want to keep it moving
right you're just kind of like in that
cycle yeah and it's
it's like you know when you're employed
i feel it's easy to be like i don't
really want to go to work today and then
when you leave work you're like yeah
fine
i'm not at work anymore physically left
yeah like there's no way of like
displacing like the very like
few times i've sort of felt like i could
stop thinking about like even if i'm
being unproductive like i can't
stop thinking about like it just doesn't
stop but
um yeah you do have to work on that
because burnout is
a real thing right if you want to be in
it for like the long picture
then and that's and that's like what i
feel like the past like i feel two years
sort of like
like trying to figure it out like how do
we figure it out how did you figure it
out and it was like just haven't
quite figured it's okay it takes time
because you want to keep the momentum
going yeah right
with youtube youtube is kind of an
insidious [ __ ] yeah because it requires
this
requires a certain amount of you right
right and then your
your like family and friends or you know
your partner they
you suffer too because you're yeah i'm
on this ride whether i like it or not
right right i'm with you and i you know
we support each other
and uh we're a team also
it's kind of funny because in the videos
it almost looks like everyone's
just having fun and like oh yeah so it's
prone together
like right but your actual life is like
nothing like that you're sitting at a
computer
yeah you don't socialize you don't go
out you're saying you don't even have a
weekend
like we did then people tell you exactly
stop come don't complain because you're
the best job ever sometimes it is like
and like you get those pockets right
like the stuff that you show people like
okay how do i set up a situation where
you are having fun and i think like
the example i can think of right now we
filmed something the other day over
discord which was pretty fun
um but we when we did the vacuuming
video where we had all the
roomba or knockoff roombas doing like
the competitions like i had
like seven six or seven people at the
house like just other youtube channels
and it was a total like [ __ ] show but in
my mind i'm trying to figure out like
okay like
like what do we have to do to sort of
make this feel fulfilling right like
because the idea i started with at the
beginning was to just
have a bunch of pudding and like put the
vacuum cleaner through and just see what
happens but then
is that the whole video i like what if
it's a contest you know and then the
whole time i'm sitting there like is
this too
stupid like oh yeah stupid you know what
i don't know well
set up the situation and you just are
there and your friends and like you know
during a lot of you're laughing and
having fun but like there's still a lot
of stress of like i need to like figure
out how to make this happen because i
have everybody here
yeah like i don't want to waste their
time at the end of the day if i come out
with nothing
and like we tried to use an editor for
that video and the first cut i got back
from them i like [ __ ] my pants oh this
is horrible
yeah like this i know that too it's so
bad because they focused on the vacuum
cleaners i'm like
that's not the interesting part the part
is like this the dynamic horrible
situation we've set up
where we have you know putting on a
carpet and just absolute chaos
you know in a house like and that's you
know what the end the final edit sort of
focuses on instead of the actual
he does all of the editing and he's tr i
can't even count how many
people he's tried at it and it just
doesn't it doesn't work and
so that's again people have no idea how
much time goes into editing
yeah i think so it's the worst it's a
lot absolutely worst part and a lot of
times like i'll film stuff after the
fact to like fill in the gaps or like
this is like
like when the header cut my hair like i
filmed it and like it's like the most
boring part of the video is the actual
haircut like people don't realize that
like
comments it's like you know something
rude or whatever like with ian where
they're like simp and this
and you're like all this work that i've
done it's just like that's what it gets
boiled down to is this mean
comment because you can't help but you
know not necessarily fixated on that but
when
everyone is just like throwing it at you
and tweeting this and that it's like
you notice how like like a mean comment
has like a hundred times the power of a
nice comment
yeah of course it's the worst and i was
always just like
i mean i for the most part don't read
comments anymore i poke through them
yeah i'll be careful but like i don't
look at it like i've even
sort of had to like really nail down
this like train of thought like if i see
a comment that really gets me going
cause sometimes people will just like
they'll find like the little crack
and then they like like a week they got
they found that like yeah
something that you think about back your
mind and you wouldn't yeah you know
because like like one of the things
would be like you know like all the
original videos on my channel are like
very like science oriented and i just
have been sort of deviating because it
tends to be a lot of work to do those
videos and it's like there's a lot of
other stuff going on i'm trying to deal
with my life
and so you know when i see people say
stuff like that just like oh it's so
frustrating especially if they're mean
about it
um and if i ever have like the energy to
want to reply to them or i'm just like i
want to say like you know fu
uh i'll try to direct that and find some
people who are like being nice
and like reply to them and stuff that's
great like because that's who deserves
it
and the mean ones you know are like they
just
makes you i stopped looking at it like
years and years ago because i'm like
dope and beautiful
my my mom used to sort of text me like
this person's being a jerk to you and
i'm like mom don't look at the comments
it's his number one fan by the way and
she like gets really mad because you
know youtube like you
that'll turn off the alarm sometimes
like notifications and she's like
your video was up and i didn't know
she's like i wake up to be the first one
to watch it
that's funny and on her breaks at work
she'll put it on silent and just replay
it
oh my god wow she loves she's like his
number one
mom's little biggest supporter like all
the stuff i bought him as a kid that
bread boards and all these like things
i wish my mom
you know needs to get a normal job i
think not i think you're doing pretty
good now
yeah i don't think he can hate anymore
no he can't but he's still you know he's
the hater
he had done as much his mom has always
been like the number one but his mom is
also
from sweden so once you say that like oh
yeah it like it pays the bills and stuff
then they're just like oh i don't
understand it but okay my mom though has
just been like
super excited she's like oh my family
are engineers and that was my son
yeah i don't know i just where do you
get all these shirts
oh really okay so it's a combination it
started with my sister
so my sister would like for christmas or
or birthday she would give me
cat shirts because she didn't know what
to get those are really good like as
someone who
has a background in clothing with ela
like that's a really nice print
i think i have like all of the possible
cat shirts yeah
i think so every time i was like has in
our like
his uh cat shirts take over two drawers
and i had to put them in the office
because there's so many of them like
okay
do you make a i love that do you make a
conscious selection or you just grab
um depends if something that i know i
have fits like if if you're doing
something that
involves like electricity like i've got
one with like there's like lightning
right
right right right right um but sometimes
you're gonna pick whatever
you were doing something it was like a
fourth of july like laughing yeah then
you got like an american one where the
cat's got sunglasses it's like a meow
so i also do buy so i'll buy ones if i
see them that are like a specialty
so i definitely contribute to the issue
but most i would say 70
of them are sent to him that's amazing
it's awesome
that's a nice shirt free clothes i just
gotta figure out how to turn them in the
pants and i don't have to buy any
questions
well um i think we're going for about
two hours
wow is there anything else to discuss
i'd like to see you hit that meat
mountain in your pocket
it really sticks out quite a bit yeah
that's so gross
and and do you have pl i mean i know you
can't be happy with the hair situation
oh i hate it
my mom keeps asking if she can come his
mom came over
the next day because i sent a picture
with her haircutting kit
and was like let me fix this and he was
like no i hate getting my hair cut i
hate getting my hair cut and we found
this
this are you embarrassed to go out in
public like that no i just
dude i stopped caring a long time ago
you just you you start to feel like
probably the first time it was
embarrassing but now it's like
yeah like what are they gonna do stay
away from me uh
so we found a girl that you look like
you have coronavirus
um and she uh she was going she like she
watched the videos and she like came to
the park one day we were filming a thing
there and i put out a thing on twitter
like come in the park and help us with
this
um and she was like going to like
hairdressing school
and so then i basically would pay her to
come to the house and cut our hair
at the last house and then you like you
weren't like me you were like hey would
it be okay because i'm really bad at
he's so bad at scheduling like it's so
hard to get him because he's always like
working doing stuff it's so hard
so she was like yeah that would be
awesome so she would come over and like
yeah like once
she came in like got like half the
people like like three or three people
there's like four guys i think actually
ian was at the house yeah you got a
haircut
and yeah we all got haircut yeah
my well my mom's she's retired but she
used to be a hairdresser so did she cut
your hair yeah yeah cause otherwise
i'm not gonna go travel to a barber
i mean it's insane it's like it's so
much effort cut his hair growing up
it's insane and then yeah that i just
don't like doing it you need a buzzer
though cause you just buzzed the whole
thing
yeah like what you can't save this the
sides are like
to the scalp well she did that so get
him don't
say she did that he said for this video
i want to mull it and i'm like okay so
then if you'll just
in the video i gave him a multi he's
like no make it shorter on the sides
because i
did short like yeah business and he's
like no shorter
shorter so i'm like okay i don't know
how to use it and i just she did what
you want
i bought i bought pink hair dye too but
i want to uh no
i want to show them correction he said
the only way he would shave his beard
because i hate it so much he's had it
since quarantine
the beard is is rough i hate the shirt
he said the only way he'll shave it is
if i
buy hot no oh is that what you wanted
that's [ __ ] um that is the craziest
[ __ ] bro
that is disgusting that is but i bought
the pink dye the next day because he
said i'll shave it if i can dye it what
about
the next day i bought it it's been
sitting there for weeks so what's
happening
you seen the one where they do the ring
around the head too yeah that's awesome
yeah
wait let me pull that up oh no don't
give him ideas
that one is really cool well he can't do
it there's a guy on
uh uh the vlog squad uh uh ugg it's
joe ugh it's joe yeah exactly he's done
a bunch of wild hairstyles like that
has he done this he's my role model for
for bad hair
i think he did do the loop let me look
at his instagram this is the one that i
love
this one isn't that [ __ ] amazing
no it's not amazing i don't think i can
do that i think oh oh
gross he's got like really low neck hair
because that is a really complicated
thing
i think i can do that now no you have to
grow on the side william yeah the
sideburns
this fully open it because it's it's
blocked by the uh picture in picture
if i so they [ __ ] up their if i click
it it will go to some random website oh
god
all right i guess we get the idea you
get the idea yeah yeah yeah i get the
idea and i'm not happy that
william hasn't and then the other one
that i like is um
yeah this is totally oh uh oh what was
the one you showed me i want to show the
audience
it's like two the double ring yeah
double ring
it looks kind of like homer simpson
honestly maybe just type like awful
yeah i think i just looked up yeah
terrible beards or something
these are just poor dudes who are
getting clowned on for a week facial air
coming up that was not the idea yeah why
cup where
why is conan getting clowned on this is
23 hot dudes with
bad facial hair [ __ ] you his beard looks
great just look at that
mannequin how dare you beard normally
looks like that
this is not normal yeah that i can
approve
wait i hate crazy beers
it just did it on my face it's like too
much room for like dirt and food
food mountains
[Laughter]
you would see you couldn't do that by
yourself you'd have to go to something
yeah you that's a professional i know
he'll never do that so yeah sure do it
baby oh this dude put it dude a bird
cage around
there that can't be rude it is real what
no yeah it's real how gross
it's real bro well you don't know no
i've seen this they had a competition
it's real i'm telling you i know the
video that you're talking about and that
video is fake
so dan you don't know anything i do
that's a birdcage beard
dude it's awesome
here here's another photo tell me it's
not real
just tell me this isn't real i mean that
one maybe is real maybe this was
inspired by that fake video that you're
referring to
i thought somebody did it for every
was the bird video that that video was
fake i mean i
refuse to believe this isn't real i
think the jacket is kind of something
william i can see like a little bit of
the gear yeah he
is um no that the only thing that really
is
what is this it's just a squirrel why is
his face look
so round that looks photoshopped
i didn't know what i was looking at
that's funny it kind of looks like
it looks like a mug like homer simpson i
think the one that he showed you the way
that it kind of makes sense i'm
trying to find it because i want to go
oh is that keemstar
the darker the beard the more evil look
the beard doesn't match the hair
like oh you can keemstar's beard looks
fake too it just looks like ink
black that doesn't look big that's got
to be fake well that's asking his age so
he probably just dies
question mark that's a good one
i'm impressed with some of these things
what's the longest you've grown your
beard out
dude not not long because because you
can grow a beard yeah but once it gets
like a little longer than this
it just gets so disgusting and curly
there's a threshold like i think once
you get
like a couple weeks beyond that it's it
starts to like escape the
i've never escaped the atmosphere
william looks like he's stopping from
there
every time i like let it go and then
trim it people always compliment my way
they're like oh you lost weight
because it's like think about a lot of
the stuff in youtube like here it's like
you look like you just gained a lot of
weight have you guys seen this watch
this
oh
can you see it dan yeah he's a cruiser
it's my favorite it's his tick-tock
this is the oldie
i think he's in court or something where
he's like
did he bring a lighter oh and i love him
something in the trunk
adventures yeah they're really bad yeah
look at his dentures are all [ __ ] up
oh here you go oh yeah people did that
people did that when because william
posted a picture or something and said
like if you do this i'll put it in the
next video
and people definitely sent him pictures
oh man that's
crazy
i'm trying to find the one you showed me
oh why what in the [ __ ]
that one disturbs me i hate like ring
beard
maybe no i don't know how do you search
for that what is the name of the style i
don't know
ring beard unfortunately i did find it
or maybe i put bad bad beards they're
just clowning on poor uh
conan o'brien can give you the
description on the instagram page that
it's on
yeah give me okay ugly design without
any spaces wait i'm going i'm just okay
let's go
let's do it ugly i just realized
whenever i went back to jk
uh jk jk ruffle
flopping aesthetic okay new start new
aesthetic new life baby oh i think i
i think i found it oh that's weird oh
there's cigarettes on her
oh that's a good look oh gross
are those tone i can't look at this
okay dan found it i can't look what did
you search for
i just went to that page you were
talking about okay
that's probably the most disgusting [ __ ]
i don't know what new start new
aesthetic baby
see i found this picture as like after
he
did the where he shaved right here i was
like oh look at how gross this one is
like thing haha and then he was like
i'm gonna do that i think you could do
it yeah i think a lot of dudes could do
that one actually
because if even if you have a patchy
beard you just kind of it also looks
like he has no chin
right that's terrible i [ __ ] hate
this yeah this is the worst god ever
wrong kind of ratty hair
do you have anything about jk ruffling
well i mean i i did find a tweet but
that was a pretty long like
saga of and then she she wrote a whole
blog post that was really
long i don't know i really really really
really want the whole thing dumbledore
was gay
how do you feel about that great great i
mean that was obvious
what did you call it i felt like it was
really what evidence was there that
dumbledore was gay
just like just like the way that he
treated everyone
his like i never imagined the compassion
just the way he was so accepted
yeah never crossed my mind sexuality
yeah yeah i didn't think about
either it was picked up on in the scene
when he sucked snape's dick
i just think like his it's acceptance
and stuff it was something that was
when it came out it was like yeah i was
like i feel like i did know that but i'm
like oh no i guess it didn't
say anything and so was there anyone
else that
that they've changed sexuality post or
made clear
it was just dumbledore's gay well she
never she just
made it like i think there was a
question people were like oh
is this yeah is this true or is this not
true and she's like yeah no it is
i feel like you get a couple of those
maybe but like if you start like
changing a bunch of stuff after like
start like clarifying things after the
fact it's like just let the books be
i wouldn't comment because she does
extensive um like the potter more like
she has extensive
um you know background and additional
information and all that that's been
going on for years
is she the richest woman in the world no
it's jeff bezos's wife
oh yeah from the divorce isn't that
awesome isn't that crazy
half of somebody's money and you're
still like i don't know we were just
talking about that the other day was it
more never less than half
it was less okay i think she got like 30
billion
it's [ __ ] awesome i bet you they
could have gotten more
but like probably they're rich she
should have got a better lawyer so much
money so what does that mean because the
lawyer gets a cut of that
looks like the the richest woman in the
world is actually the the walton
uh walmart yeah the walmart uh heiress
dude goes down the cover jeff bezos
you put her in the top ten maybe is that
what happened oh yeah she's a looks like
four number four man that's a that's a
[ __ ] settlement right there
boy alice alice oh she's rich as [ __ ]
that what do you think what do you do
with 54 billion dollars i have no idea
steal
[ __ ] health care from low paid
workers
like i just that boggles my mind like
just creep like people are so
like disassociated from but especially
walmart it's like dude you don't even
give
like you like cut people's hours so that
they don't have full-time employment and
they live on food stamps
there was a post on reddit yesterday of
a t-shirt they like i don't know if it
was one walmart or was a corporate thing
that they gave to their employees and it
was like the
what's the flag statue where they're
lifting the flag up like the soldiers
oh yeah that's yeah iwo jima marine did
you see there's like the walmart
interpretation of it where it shows
like the doctors the empty firefighters
and then the lifting the walmart flight
yeah the walmart
vest like lifting the american flag and
it's like they posted that
and then pull that up oh an employee
posted that yeah okay it i
i yeah it looks real l'oreal
man hair products what's up dude i would
not have thought of that yeah
how do you make your life better with 50
billion dollars i don't know their
shampoo is bomb though they got that
fruity ass shampoo
oh i hate that well you obviously don't
know what you're talking about because
she's worth 50 billion dollars look at
her hair looks kind of like her hair
yeah she's got some loose ends there
what do you call that little split
she's got split ends for sure wait this
is a pretend
she's this is a really bad endorsement
for her
i don't think they do only shampoo
though i think they do probably do
beauty
yeah and yeah i don't think the [ __ ]
family
wow 38 billy billy what do these [ __ ]
do
the coke family the [ __ ] family yeah
the cup what do they do they sell oil or
do they say underneath
why aren't there so many billionaires
you would think no you do what do you
even do with that money
the the co coke industries uh involved
in the manufacturing of petroleum
chemicals energy fiber polymers they're
in the polymer business
polymer it's all oil it's all oil yeah i
guess
what's the bell dumpling mystery box oh
she's spitting a
sent it to us actually yeah yeah you
want to smell it no
we occasionally get it out and smell it
it was a big mistake last time
i'm kind of curious no your curiosity is
done
the spit of an internet legend is in
that yeah stop
you made me look at like videos this is
like this is the like the
the grounding that i need in my mind
yeah you watch that stupid
bathwater one and i was like no oh well
so so she's the internet for today
there's also belly lint in there if you
want
really from skippy the virginia virgin
we have a jarvis
body something for the ladies as well
when she was doing the bath while we
were coming up with all sorts of ideas
and i like i can't i think we had ideas
other people did where they were testing
the water but like what if you made like
a pot of mac and cheese with it
that's a good idea
i was like shut it down shut it down you
know what i was trying to do
uh i tried to get her to fart in a jar
and send it to me she wouldn't
no she sent a spit instead
because i was like that'd be awesome oh
my gosh uh
mackenzie bezos yeah crushing it
jacqueline mars who's that mars bars oh
candy
what dude that mars crazy
that's crazy and then 35 billion dollar
candy
wait is it kind of funny that they make
pet food and
yeah what pet like i wonder what name
must be some like one of the
big brands wow
that explains why mars bars taste like
dog food do you think that much money
would make your life worse
um like do you think it would bring i
think at a certain point
of wealth like once you cross a billion
or
not i mean billions like trust anyone
that likes you for you it's all just
going to be i feel like it would just be
super like
i don't know i really i couldn't even
empathize with being that rich
it just it feels like you see all the
stories of people winning the lottery
and just like destroys their lives
yeah because they have no they have no
right systems
right in place to handle then think of
like the fact that you like you ha
you're so well
you have to have systems in place to
handle that you know yeah you have to
have systems even get that farm right
in business just like who do you you
know how do you have like genuine
relationships with people or it like
forces you to like only have
relationships with like a certain
like class of people who are closer i
think there's a lot of that
for sure like i even feel weird you know
doing the youtube stuff because like
you know like i'd still consider myself
like a normal person and like you know
occasionally someone will
like recognize you on the street but
people will talk to me
and there's always like the suspicion or
this kind of like you know like
hesitation of knowing in my mind how i
perceive
people on youtube back in the day and
like being careful with how i
communicate things to them or like what
i say
because it's almost like you're giving
them a bunch of like information that
they you know what i'm saying like it's
almost weird like sometimes
yeah there's definitely that level of
yeah i mean that's kind of just
like it's harder to break down into
people and be more of a human like
you're like you're defensive walls you
do
way more frequently and i am like
constantly like i
really think about what i'm saying
because because of the fact that i'm not
like exclusively in youtube right it's
like it's what my husband does
and people will ask me things and at
first you kind of think it's innocent
and you're just like talking have a
conversation be like oh wait
this is really personal like i can't you
know i i'm very aware of it at this
point this is more early on but
you can't it's like i can't tell you all
these things i can't tell you about
people i'm
you know that he's close to their
friends just because it is it's you
can't
it's a trust thing yeah yeah i mean it's
one of the it's kind of just one of the
pitfalls right
yeah but it gets worse the yeah the
higher you right and like that terrifies
me like we you know we've still had not
like super
bad problems but it's like when people
call you like that sucks like
it just sucks it sucks for everybody
sucks for them i don't even answer my
phone anymore
yeah unless i know who it is but if
you're like expecting someone to call
and you don't know what the number is
going to be
i don't answer it it [ __ ] my life so
many times we miss deliveries or
yeah i just don't answer questions i
don't answer i don't you see how you
think the day like we just had our roof
done and he's like oh i need to call you
for something today but i don't have the
number like you know the call from
different number not the
company one i'm like it's a huge gamble
when you answer on
yeah i do i get very anxious right yeah
i know a lot of people have two
phones yeah i don't want to carry two
phones
yeah just yeah yeah that's the life baby
you made it
uh yeah it gets worse that aspect gets
worse
but you get used to it but i'm obviously
but like
you guys have had i think probably the
worst of some of the people like
uh yeah i mean as bad as you can on just
being a youtuber yeah
although we don't have stalker like
nobody wants to [ __ ] me so i think that
that's it that's a i've word but do you
have to deal with those people that like
want to get you no one wants to [ __ ] me
well i'm like for people i think people
want to [ __ ] you but i think the fact
that we're married and have a kid
right makes the people get obsessed with
you know you can't control when someone
is obsessed
but i'm not a heartthrob like there's
like these single women
and women who are like heart throbs and
they play up into the angle
so i think that's another angle that's
probably creepy i definitely am glad
that i'm not
we don't you're i think you're a heart
but you're married
yeah yeah i don't know i think people
think he never had it that's i mean look
at this
yeah that's not true thank you
i would stalk you thank you you're
welcome
yeah i was the only people that would
stalk him are going to be like
kids that are like science nerds yeah
it's never really
it's always just kind of like like we've
actually seen kids sort of approach the
house too and they almost like realize
at that point like oh this is not a good
idea i've gone too far like they realize
what they've done and they realize they
start to get those feelings of like i'm
approaching a stranger
when they start thinking about like how
am i gonna like what am i gonna say what
am i gonna do
yeah and they're like actually this is a
bad idea i think the only people that
have actually
approached the house ring the doorbell
or whatever come to the house to talk to
me
are people who are not i don't mean this
as insult
but it's just an observation it kind of
has to be true that they have some kind
of
something some kind of uh yeah or
they're really young that was sort of
like
some sort of mental health issues yeah
like i would i would say
where they don't think that that's a
string i think i think a lot of them
have some
some level of autism where they don't
understand they can't put the yeah
yeah exactly because they'll they'll
come up to you and they're super nice
and
they act like they don't understand
anything that anything's wrong with this
right and they're really nice kind of
like a kid like when the kid does like
they don't get
a lot of but it's like dude you know
it's like
right cool to meet you but you know you
can't do this
yeah and then do you ever feel like
people are kind of like like someone's
looking at you from the corner like if
you're at the grocery store yeah always
always always are they like do i smell
bad or do they
no they know who you are i love you you
know sometimes it's just like random you
like it they have no idea
just you had like a weird feeling for
some reason or you go to you know
vidcon although it got canceled oh i've
never seen here
you went to vidcon and i get really um
hounded because they won't want to
necessarily go to him because especially
if he's doing something or they can see
and i'm kind of standing you know i'm
like
i'm the wife clearly [ __ ] with me and
all this stuff and they're like you know
21 questions about william
again because she's not used to that
because like he's like you're just
normal people but when you're
concentrated like in an area
because they want to know like as a
child and did it
as a child like all these questions and
you know it's super
like genuine that what they want to know
but then you're like oh this is a lie
and it's very information you have to
say then you have to skirt the oh it's
very unusual you feel rude when you're
like hey i can't
right i can't tell you that right yeah
but you never would do that in your
normal day life it's very strange
because she's like she's not
like been trained to like put the walls
up kind of
protect her be careful like what i think
i've gotten like you get used to it
right but again it's like it's not like
it you make your first youtube video and
it happens overnight it's a very gradual
and slow thing and
we we don't go to the we used to go to
one grocery store and that was like
every time guaranteed we went yeah
everything that was it was always
pleasant experiences it was always
positive yeah but
i mean i scream at william a lot when
he's doing stupid things which is very
often
in public people are like oh my gosh
really i
if he's doing something i mean i'm just
like the shopping cart yeah
like stop it like william get off and
get the water have we ever had a fight
we've had
maybe a couple times fights in public
but i think we're both very
aware of like we can't yeah we gotta we
gotta keep this together
for now once and i told you i said you
can't do that right now
yeah just keep it together at the park
we're doing that yeah and i was probably
mad at you for a very valid reason
i probably did something but i was like
you can't yeah but just pull it together
and they have cameras and like no i know
we'll get in the car and then we'll talk
to you
just yell at me in the car yeah just
hold it
he was like thank god that we're here
he's like let me run out of the car and
go to the safety of these people i'm
like
we need guys like us need carers yes oh
my god you have no idea
i i'm not a very responsible adult
i get about there's i have no visual cue
that would lead me to believe that
yeah sort of nothing about you he made
him an ideal
consequence he okay so he's a
responsible adult
in certain things like he's really
responsible with finances like
even like before youtube like he would
take care of our taxes like he's really
responsible with a like
certain specific that's a good one so
it's a really good one
completely irresponsible he's really i
won't do my laundry though yeah i'll
just let it but that'll let
that's just different levels of of of
care yeah like i will go until i'm out
of underwear yeah
that doesn't find when we first started
dating he would go inside out
yeah and pull underneath like that's
fine that's who he died
to me that's fine but i like
legitimately have obsessive-compulsive
disorder and like that's hence like i
have a therapist you think it's not okay
for me to wear the same thing it is not
the things that will give me anxieties
like i don't even ask
him to do it not on purpose it's never
going to happen
just yeah we'll see i think i can
do all the cleaning because it has to be
done the way that i need it to be to
control my anxiety
and so he's like she's like a different
level of like
it works why don't you get a cleaner but
we come to agreements together because
there was a time when like
i wasn't working as much so i was cool
doing it but then
now i work a lot so i'm like well [ __ ]
that i'm not doing it
but we just gotta clean her yeah because
i was never gonna wash dishes to the
level that i should
right i just i can't do it i hate it i
just throw them in the dishwasher yeah i
just throw them out and buy new ones
put them in the dresser they'll put them
in the dishwasher yeah but the thing is
you gotta rinse it in the dishwasher
well
just don't i can't tell you when and i'm
like well you know but
but i'll do it later in the day not
immediately it's very
yeah how often do you have a cleaner uh
we
at the la house we were run uh we were
renting the house and we were hiring a
cleaner because it was
i saw her in the background of the
roomba video yeah they were absolutely
mortified
um she she's like i have to clean that
yeah well we actually did mostly because
the carpet we bought a piece of carpet
so the carpet was just sitting there but
it did leak through a little bit
i also let the carpet sit there for like
a month outside not in the house outside
with all yellow on it with uh pudding
yeah and it was all right it was rotten
and i couldn't [ __ ] try all by myself
because it was too heavy
and so i ended up having to like cut it
up so i could fold it to fit in the
trash
that's disgusting like i made a mistake
i should have thrown this away
immediately
because that doesn't it's like it's not
in the house
yeah yeah they that at that place
because michael and i were living there
yeah and and
michael is does not clean anything and
so it was like we have to hire cleaners
because i i don't want to do it and i
didn't i really don't want her to be
like
you've got to get it clean that to me is
like one of the first most necessary
luxuries you can get when you're
successful i think it's but that is time
much better i'm still gonna clean after
cleaning up so that's
that's your product because i have food
but that's because it's something that i
oh my god but would it help you at all
um certain things like so
what if you could teach her to clean
like you clean yeah
there are certain things i don't like i
really enjoy cleaning because it's an
anxiety
yeah i do and i have since i was little
wow it's an anxiety reducing
behavior for me so there are certain
things i don't like though like i don't
like cleaning baseboards
i don't really particularly i don't
think i've ever cleaned a baseboard what
even i don't know what that is what are
we talking about
the face like oh my god oh it
what's your favorite cleaning supplies
lysol nice like i love spraying lines
you like the white
i like the wipes the wipes i use in the
bathroom every day
i just that i have issues with the
clarksville because now they're the best
i'm in therapy okay wait besides the
baseboards what do you
not so there's just some things like i'm
not a huge fan of mopping
i do it but i'm not a huge fan of it so
i'm like i could have someone do that
someone could mop
yeah certain things but i'm still the
kind of per i'm still going to clean
every day i'm not going to deep clean
every day but have a cleaner every day
still going to clean every day even
with work and everything yeah we have a
cleaner every day
of doing it what about so which ones do
you like
uh so i really like i love vacuuming
yeah she knows you have to definitely
only when i'm like on vacuum
like the phone comes up boom vacuum
comes out so you have the desk
i love like that like you know where
you're cleaning something and you see
something dirty and then it's clean
so i love cleaning the bathroom i love
cleaning the bathroom do you clean the
toilet
yeah you like it scrubbing the toilet
what about like that behind the toilet
yep
wow what about like the whole toilet
what about like do you ever see piss
around the toilet no i do pretty good
job
what about when he was living with other
dudes did you clean their piss oh he's
clever because of me
yeah we had our own bathroom and he knew
how
you got to do it you got to do it yeah
he knows that it's like i was going to
build a thing that detected piss on the
seat and then blasted the toilet but he
knows that for me like
me my cleaning stuff isn't because i'm
like wanting to be controlling it's like
it's something that i've
done with my whole life yeah um and you
know i didn't do therapy my whole life
for it and stuff but after the fire my
anxiety
oh my god so i started seeing a
therapist for the fire because i had
really bad ptsd
and then work i started finally like
acknowledging and working on
the ocd so for me it's an anxiety
i feel like i feel like it was a
combination of the fire plus immediately
moving into a motor home
yeah we also had that was not luxurious
yeah and
not only a motorhome but a motor home on
the property of my
in-laws yeah i know that's that's brutal
and sharing we were sharing there was a
bathroom it was his
mother his sister william and i in one
bathroom
and then his dad was in another bathroom
so i would like try to eat food at night
and have to be super quiet because it's
like you know you're
it's a it's a motor home like it's the
table and the bed right there and it'd
be like
like eating a cracker but like letting
it sit in my mouth
to get less salty so that i could like
chew it without making her up
yeah that's crazy yeah man
that that's a wild having your house
burned down is not uh
experienced most people we haven't lived
in the latest for more than
one year since the house since then yeah
just like every
at the end of the lease it's like the
last place they said they weren't going
to renew the lease yeah
and then they immediately rented it for
like 20 percent more money
left i don't even know if that's legal
um
yeah probably i wonder yeah i'm not sure
i think it might depend on where it is
would you have paid 20
more if they asked you no no not for
that place
there's just other like other issues and
things going on with you yeah and so
we've just been like boop boop boop and
it's like oh my god
yeah i think you guys should get a
cleaner every every weekday
i think it's a good idea i'm still going
to clean every day
well if you if it's something that is
therapeutic for you then yeah because it
doesn't actually
feel better but if there's things that i
also would never let anyone do my
laundry
i have really severe issues with that
because as a
like i had laundry stolen as a kid he's
laundromats
uh yeah and then i also you know like
people like messing up your clothes or
like shrinking
or like you know i know how to take care
his stuff you i could care less about it
but my thing is it's like okay i don't
want my sweater to be
you know shrunk i got that i mean but
these these these cleaners they know
what they're doing man
it would be a long process for me to
gain trust okay
i i understand but but at the other i
mean like the the house where
you know the science house i'm like all
for it because i
don't want to clean them up for other
people yeah i my own
but you know our house when it's messy
it's like nothing because of my
standards yeah like everything that's a
good mom quality
organized i mean it's pretty glorious i
feel like we both have
in my class sort of in the same way like
it works well like i sort of do a lot of
stuff but i'm a little bit messier i
feel like we have the exact same dynamic
yeah
although i thrive off of organization
and structure
like for me yeah i think i think ila too
and i'm just a
lazy [ __ ] slob dude just like chaos
i'm just chaos yeah brace the chaos like
bottled the chaos yeah you gotta you
gotta have the balance if you don't have
that balance things just go all in one
direction forget when i first came to
your apartment and
ethan just all of his clothes were just
in a pile on the floor you know what's
wrong with the pile on the side
like just like
crazy to me like a laundry file that
someone like
did all that mine would go between the
bed and the wall i would shove it in
like that
cause i would watch all of his clothes i
would wash it then i would dump
it yeah because i didn't want to fold it
but you know what's crazy to me is that
i didn't get rid of that in preparation
for you coming
yeah you weren't like oh my goodness
what did you get
before she came what was like the worst
oh i think we were moving out
that's why it was you were moving out
yeah we were moving out it looked like
but the second time you came ela my room
was clean
don't lie about it i don't remember wait
the
yes wait when you came and i was staying
in
my own room in that big house
the room the yeah you know by the santa
cruz diner
the whole situation yeah this is like
before you had the pile of clothes
oh i thought you talked about the other
house
i
did i shove it all in the closet yeah oh
yeah but it was still on the floor
i trapped it in the closet so she
wouldn't i see it
no yours was shoved behind your bed like
his bed went up against the wall and
there was because there was stuff in the
closet i didn't even think i used the
closet i didn't
know his closet had like science
stuff in it like like yeah yeah
science stuff is messy you want a good
closet story sure
we were in the motor home i uh we used
the shower
for storage clothes and stuff like that
so it was basically closet
because motorhomes have no space to keep
clothes and i'm like i'm a teacher i
have to look nice every day and i can't
wear the same thing
so we used the bathroom and the sink in
that motorhome
because it was a pain in the butt to go
down to my parents house because we were
like kind of
up on the hillside um and we didn't have
any drainage for it and so we'd have to
drive the motor home across town down to
like
harbor to dump it and so we would do
this like once a month
we pushed it a little bit too far was it
more we pushed it a little bit too hard
and it started backing up into the
shower oh it's worse
we were we were in texas visiting my
grandparents
so we were gone for a week and didn't
know that had happened so the used
gray water was slowly filling up the
bottom of the shower with all of our
stuff in
so wait was there there wasn't like
feces or no the gray water is like the
sink water the
black water is the poopy water so so it
doesn't sound that dirty if you just
wash your hands in it
oh it was it's like dishes and
so you brush your teeth when you're
washing dishes
but it like gets like really narrow and
that got all over you
yeah yeah so then again so the fire
happened and i lost you know
you know it's like you know but then it
flooded the shower that had
like all my shoes and like it was
basically like like five or six so i
just throw away water and like she had a
pair of like uggs like boots yeah
completely like bugs and i had like like
other
like running shoes like awesome you're
like you can't clean that you just throw
it away and there were some sweaters and
yeah
it was just it was so fun it was like
yay
grey water so fun don't live in a room
so have you just been
become like a guru that doesn't care
about any belongings now because you've
just like
no i think i appreciate things more so i
remember
like you know you have like the thing
like oh this is a special thing and you
need to keep it
safe like or you know like my grandma
gave me her pearls from when she was 18
and
i was always so afraid to wear them so
often because i'm like these are
for my grandma and these are old and i i
love them and i appreciate them but i
was afraid to wear stuff
because i'm like i don't want to ruin it
mm-hmm and then they burned and you're
like
well how's it going stupid i mean i wore
i mean i wore them for some really
special
occasions like i i wore those for my
graduation i wore those on our wedding
day you know things like that like i
have memories and pictures
but um it made me go like
if you're not gonna get used out of
something and you're not gonna enjoy it
then what's the point of having it so
it made me more appreciative of the
things that i have and
more selective like when i get things
like is this gonna
actually make me happy makes you realize
a lot of stuff doesn't matter and then a
lot of things don't matter and the
things that did i wish that i would have
not been so careful with them and and
same thing with like my mother-in-law
she after because their house was you
know close to
burning and my father-in-law saved it um
the same thing she's like you know these
things that had put away these precious
family heirlooms she's like i need these
out and display because what's the point
it also makes you realize that you want
to have all your documents in one place
easy to grab do we have that deal
sort of sort of because it's a pain
yeah we had to get everything we had
just gotten our passwords like we had
just rushed our passports because we had
done it certificates
passed and we had to do it all in our it
was like social security cards
passports marriage certificates we got
in
um all of that that's good advice yeah
so to have it a tax return i mean
that's probably the most important thing
because that will save you actually
weeks of
like stress yeah and then money too like
for our passports
i was on the phone with them and a lot
of them they did it for free
because of the fire natural disaster
passports they were like
no you had to pay and i was about to go
to europe to see my cousin
and so i'm like i need my passport and i
need it in three weeks so like okay so
you paid
expedited i'm like but it burned last
week like
i didn't lose it it burned so i really
had to pay that and they're like they
don't care we don't
like [ __ ] you this is the fee and you're
like i just lost
everything and i just want to go i was
still you know my cousin's like you can
cancel like no i want to go see you
because
i live in a motor home now there's grey
water
my mother thank you yeah and then going
everywhere i was like
okay i was calling people because i was
going to europe and it was cold
like who could let me borrow a jacket
who cares
because i didn't have time to go find
this stuff let alone you know
it's just it was more of the
psychological
too like it was hard to have to admit
that you had to replace things
yeah like i'll just borrow from someone
because i still have that
there exactly yeah
okay yeah no i do not so
well nothing i would like to close this
episode with you
taking a bite of the meat mountain in
your pocket well
good news is it's easily accessible it's
probably like hot
it's been in there for like two hours or
an hour and a half for sure it's warm
is it warm that one side's cool the
other side
oh well there's something else i want to
discuss with you before
before we end this before after uh you
can go for it ew
what did you wait let me get a look at
that before you go in kind of shiny
oh man it looks like there's horsey
sauce on it but there's not
there is probably there is now but i
think that's just straight up rot
it still smells like a sandwich oh
garbage garbage
garbage
oh come on william back in the pocket
baby for later
yes um
all of our tree oliver tree broke the
coughing beanie oh you did can you
diagnose the issue
it got dropped many many times oh yeah
very floppy
oh that's maria there's a lot of moving
parts
the the hair cutting you got that from
her
the girl who used to cut his hair yeah
you have like a she hooked up it up with
a
mannequin so what's the problem here
um it's so good
yep it's uh it's smashed it looks like
well
actually
i remember those zip ties
you don't really need that in there
anymore what was that for
the micro or the speaker
that's a fan it's so good
because the fan was to put this
[Music]
i can't believe it still works how's
that possible that thing's been there
for like this to be charged for years
it's been off
it's just double a batteries this this
recharge though i think
yeah because i never figured out how to
well i didn't figure i just didn't even
try to figure out how to power it
um all you gotta do is charge that
that's it yeah perfect wait but so i
mean we just assumed it was yeah we
assumed it was broken because it was all
like
i mean it's a little bit broken yeah
like the stuff's just like flopping
about but
yeah he was wearing it and it and it
fell off until yeah i mean like all this
stuff was part of the smoke which i took
out because i didn't want to burn your
guys's office yeah sure
um but other than that it just i think
this is probably so what do we need to
do
to operate it again i mean there's just
it's just a switch
right is it double a's yeah mm-hmm
but this already works and then that's
just dead and then you just plug that in
and then this plays
the sound over this right here so we can
make a comeback on
yeah yeah it's going that's amazing it
works yeah it's kicking yeah this is
back when i used to make science videos
yeah right you finished filming that
at when we lived in the hotel yeah this
is right when the house went down
yeah and then it was in the hotel look
at this thing go man
is it just two no it's not gonna happen
like plugged in these batteries are
still kicking oh yeah
we don't even need to replace the
battery good yeah
well well well that's exciting
well uh william osman
crabs and science yeah yeah on twitter
you're trying to get william osman yeah
the guy but i like crabs
that's kind of how i feel i don't know
what i'm supposed to do i don't really
like the idea of someone else having my
name
yeah [ __ ] that guy your crabs and stuff
so he was willing to give it to me but
then i'm sitting do i change it oh he
was yeah
because he got he got it because of it i
would change it and then i would change
it yeah
i mean crabs of science is great but to
find right and i'm not verified now so
it's like it's probably
yeah smarter on is this on twitter
twitter yeah
so uh william ostman on on youtube
that's it that's the channel that's the
thing yeah
yeah don't worry about the takedown no
no
are you allowed to to um are you allowed
to say bad things about tick tock
i don't think they care they don't they
just want the videos yeah
i mean it's oh they're watching yeah i
mean it's like it is what it is it's
just
it's just probably not like something
that you would really
spend too much time with you know in the
big picture what
what's more which what's your time
better youtube yeah youtube
not
yeah i don't have any oh we just
recorded a like a discord game show
where we did that we had people give us
their invention ideas oh that's a great
yeah it was a total [ __ ] yeah i was
wondering did you get any good ideas
a lot of really bad ideas but there were
a couple ideas that were just like
good like one was this like uh
inflatable pregnancy sweater so that you
could like go on
like public transit and people would
feel bad and give up their seatbelts so
you like
you inflate it and then you get on and
you're like either i mean if you're a
guy that is like fat
um one that was like makes you taller
it's got like leg extenders
make you as tall as the person you're
talking to so it can like see how tall
they are
that sounds expensive yeah no i mean it
wouldn't be too bad i don't think
what's a good tick tock idea um i do see
that's the thing is i don't know
so if you fart in a jar and seal it how
long does the methane
how long does the methane stay and stay
active it would probably stay in there
for a long time because could you
so you should do one where it's like one
day later one week later
one month how do you like keep like fart
consistency though
like just you just keep eating the same
thing you're gonna eat those
yeah you think the input matters yeah
because i would think that the output
doesn't vary that much in terms of the
gas
yeah but if it like you know i mean it's
science tell me
your farts don't smell different every
time sometimes they smell like trash
sometimes they smell like a rotting
corpse
all good you know how do you tell all
right well
i'm following you i am following you on
tick tock
you are yes you have a tick tock i am i
am a
i have a viewer yeah i just i just want
to know what's going on there
and and somehow you're one of the first
channels i stumbled across and i started
following all these i think they might
be promoting the science channels
so i can't even tell people actually
want to watch the videos if they're
doing it artificially because i've just
somehow found all these science shows
but i actually like them i think they're
interesting
yeah yeah which is better than teenage
girls dancing yeah yeah
correct and that's that's my problem
it's like you know the
vast majority of what's on there is
teenage girls yeah i haven't gotten to
that portal
somehow i don't know i think you have to
take some actions to end up there
[Laughter]
no no because i haven't seen it i don't
see that many as you see lots of science
and i see lots of pranks and i see lots
you don't spend a lot of time on it
though
you would think enough where i would see
an underage girl
what's with the how is there a platform
literally that just serves you
underage girls dressed in little
clothing
really that's the whole [ __ ] platform
dude that's
crazy i don't know man that's [ __ ]
crazy don't no think about that i feel
like last i saw
they weren't in bikinis is that like a
new development yeah i think they've
generated because it in the beginning it
was more about the dance
right oh uh zach just said the biggest
tip [ __ ] is 16 years old really what's
her name zach i said
charlie yeah yeah yeah the emilio
marshmallow
her name is charlie c-h-a-r-l-i
but it started with when it was
musically it was really about wait this
girl is 16 years old and then
she's she i feel so bad for her too i
see all sorts of stuff wait is there
twins
or is that what is that a weird meme oh
because they look like identical
or i guess not they look different i
just saw her
post on twitter the other day about 16
and she's number one
yeah she's like 60 million followers or
something
and so uh yeah and so like she's like
not wearing a lot of clothes no she's
actually not so bad
but it's a lot of like yeah yeah yeah it
is
very pro yeah very productive not 16
acting it's so much
it's like it's very like just and then
people treating you like you're
very yeah and people being very
judgmental and you sort of like i seen
on twitter
i think just the other day she's
complaining about people uh like yeah i
know i'm boring because people were like
commenting on a live stream she had done
on tick tock
oh she does the same thing like she just
makes the same sounds and this and that
and they're like
just like roasting and like mean and
it's like she's 16 years old she's like
who knows you know been like propelled
by this platform
you know yeah dude i'm all that's man
and that should still yeah
it breaks my heart or the worst thing
that can happen to you as a teenager is
to become really famous
yeah right well yeah exactly i mean i i
genuinely think
most people think that i'm just being
stupid like
people are not receptive to this but
becoming famous can be the worst thing
that happens
a lot of times to people i think
especially depending on how old you are
and then what are your circumstances and
how you deal with it how your family and
all of that
i think it's similar to you know just
social media in general like what it
does to your brain is it just it
messes with how you operate on a
day-to-day basis you know like you're
either like afraid of people or like
constantly paranoid or you know
just that you're like like what rewards
you get from interacting with people may
change and you're like you're less
likely to interact with your old friends
because you don't feel as important as
like your new
more famous friends kind of thing you
know what are you guys going to be
eating for dinner
what am i going to be eating for dinner
meat mountain left probably left over me
mountain yeah
is that enough to tie you up probably
going to want to have you seen this
thing because
yeah i mean yeah i ate most of it
already i got through like half of it
but i'm wondering you did not get half
of it
is he really going to eat that uh
he's a wild card he could either
if he feels bad he might not but if he
doesn't feel
too i'm not going to eat it in one
sitting yeah but that's what i mean
like but i'm saying if like we were like
leaving and you started like ooh
my stomach's feeling bad you might not
bro you can't safely transport that from
your pocket and then you have to drive
back to
stay in my pocket until i get it out
next and eat it
that's not i'm gonna not encourage it
but i can't force him to do anything but
that's enough food for you to type
because you're like a skinny yeah fit
thank you just one meat mountain because
that's the only weight during this
covenant it's got to be like two
thousand calories i know but i'm just
telling you i can't just be satisfied
with one meme
you need two wee mountains no i need
something i'm done with the mountain
well like i eat normal foods look how
look how look how like embarrassed you
are for me it makes me sick
it makes me sick i mean you are you know
a little bit chunkier than you were on
the first podcast
the very first podcast who was there for
i mean yeah of course
yeah i know that too much what's your
point
during quarantine though he actually did
he gained like over 10 pounds
did he lose it no no i'm going to make
an invention to help
he hasn't make an invention that makes
it harder for me to eat the more i eat
even his mom
so you're dieting right now that's why
you're limiting yourself to one well not
dieting he's not dieting
or exercising
is it a problem if you get fat for you
no but i just don't want him to like
get diabetes or have a heart attack
that's why that's what you girls say but
i just don't think
and by the way there's nothing wrong
with not finding me attractive as a fat
man but i i don't think he looks
different but i also believe you don't
want him he brings it up
he's like i gained weight and he told me
i'm like no you didn't step on the scale
and i'm like
but you know it's not fun you're like
it's depressing
i know you can't run around and um
with it or you like get tired you know
yeah i know
it's about longevity like i want you to
be around for a long time
so if you eat by the way you're in great
shape
thank you yeah thank you yeah i don't
say anything
if you eat meat mountain every day you
will knock me
i can barely get me it
versus like i run and i work out like do
cardio
i do everything strength training and
he's like i'll go on maybe one walk
and usually it's like food involved once
you look i was gonna say once you look
like me then
i mean that's a journey though i don't
know but it happens i
i i mean no one in his family i've been
able to like been lucky to just stay
skinny
yeah everyone is family feel like at
that point now we're really just going i
have to be more careful yeah yeah
i don't know anyone that like really and
even your dad like
when he thinks he's a little bit over
it's like it's still no one will look at
that and go he's overweight
for the record though i just don't want
to say i did not eat finish my mead
mountain
and hila did promise me something in
return for throwing it out
so but you're gonna try to spin this
like
you do really need pizza but just
remember i could have finished that meat
mountain
what is the point that you're trying i
just wanna
yeah it's for you for pinning this
conversation for later
when i say it's time to make mistakes
and then you fight
i still want it okay but you guaranteed
me safe passage
yeah he's gonna get like meat lovers i
don't want to pay any tariffs on this
[ __ ]
man that you're making here we can get
mexican you want mexican
friday is that like preparing anything
over a pizza
yeah every friday we go because we have
the podcast then we always go
let's get [ __ ] mexican food man
well what the [ __ ] do you want eli
doesn't ever want to eat anything it's
just so annoying you just want italian
food who cares
you like you like pasta yeah it's boring
but yeah [ __ ] one hate's possible
thank you i feel like i'm the only
person that doesn't like
it's not fine it's just so [ __ ] like
okay
noodles and sauces noodles and sauce
noodles and sauce lasagna is the most
exciting hold on let's put some
green peas in it okay that didn't make a
big [ __ ] difference
noodles and sauce i made like a
penne pasta with like the beyond meat
like a baked one you liked that i mean
yeah but at the same time
just possible it's pasta yeah thank you
you liked it i did like it it's just
but if i had a choice i would honestly
eat almost anything other than pasta
it's a travesty william hates spaghetti
specifically spaghetti i [ __ ] hate
spaghetti
that's crazy that we have that same mom
just made spaghetti i hate spaghetti
and the noodles are annoying to eat it's
messy
it doesn't really eat them it doesn't
really even absorb the sauce
just like you're eating worms how are
you going to talk about that but you
have no problem eating meat
then well i thought that that [ __ ] does
not function
dude did you see how dynamic and complex
do i need to pull up the list of
ingredients again
but i've learned a couple of culinary
masterpieces he doesn't like spaghetti
so
i don't force it and i don't be like
well i'm going to like we're going to
have this
so be yeah i'm not saying that you're
crazy
he ate your shitty beyond meat
i'm just kidding he had seconds it was
actually it was actually it was really
good
but i like beyond meat i still think
pasta you know in general in general
you know what sometimes i like i like
gnocchi when it's done really well
i like that too because it's kind of
interesting it's fluffy it's just unique
it has character right dumplings
now i'm hungry but not for like i have
some time i have meat mountain in my
pocket
he has food on him we should go to a dog
park can we go dog park
no let me know in my pocket
[Laughter]
all right well uh what what else is
there to say really at this point
i don't think anything other than like
you know i mean we could figure out like
you guys want to
do some stupid stuff in the future i
think you talked about the uh gatsby
yeah
you have any ideas i mean you what do
you want to make it do
it sounds like it already goes pretty
fast what if we could give it a speed
boost for a channel they could go faster
can we add like a button like um to make
it go from like nitro yeah nitro
i mean it'd be a lot of like basically
probably well i don't know we'd have to
see what it looks like on the inside but
i mean you could definitely make it go
faster
hmm what can we do i'm gonna think about
you put a rocket on it we
do not need it to go faster that's
already an issue that's kind of what i
was thinking
some drywall in our office so you want
to do something to it to it and keep it
i think we should increase its
destructive force by
maybe fastening weapons to it
from your seat or something oh you mean
like it's 0-60
no like if you're someone's seated you
get them out of there
yeah that seems dangerous but you want
to keep it at the end of the day but
i don't care no it's destructible
because you could make it go really fast
but someone see i don't want it to be
dangerous i don't want someone to
necessarily die
not necessarily but if we mount weapons
or like punching mechanism or battery
and see you know gatsby verse
whatever i bought um
[Music]
no never mind i'll tell you later okay
but i think a gatsby verse like
concrete wall yeah gatsby verse
yeah yeah i think or plywood
drywall yeah concrete like what can't it
let's [ __ ]
let's put let's see what where the limit
is
like a replica human body like the um
ballistics gel i think that would be
fantastic
like like what would have happened to
you yes at full speed with the gatsby
like everybody's been asked i think i
think that's a really good video
a human with the gatsby i think that's a
really really good idea
and i'm not saying that sarcastically i
like i like that idea a lot like fake
bones in it and just see what happens
or be creepy like william and get real
bones yeah
were those real bones yeah you know you
can buy it he bought yeah you can buy
skulls i didn't know you bought real
bones
you can buy real skulls on yeah he he
made a big one
i looked into it he wanted to get yeah
um
but yeah it's kind of creepy whose hand
was it you bought i have no idea
somebody's yeah and it was on how did it
end up
yeah you can buy human finger bones on
amazon the whole set was a hundred bucks
for the for one finger who's [ __ ]
food
that means that somebody in a mortuary
is like punt like there's getting bones
there's like a whole history to it
apparently like i looked into it like
it's there was there it was uh there
there were problems
it wasn't on the up and up no this is
like everything and it's on amazon
yeah but they're all old bones okay you
can't buy new businesses they can't buy
them they realize
that people were turning it too much
into like a
a business profiting off of your bones
yeah
that seems honest yes and so let's just
get the
[ __ ] old idiot so everything that's
in circulation can stay in circulation
but you cannot
you can't get it so there's there's a
there's got to be quite a street value
on human rights they're expensive a
skull is like
two grand whoa yeah he went down a
rabbit hole
during this that was very very that's
interesting terrified and repulsive yeah
and i like i had you know anyways many
people told me do not buy a human skull
and so i didn't
you did didn't no i didn't he didn't i
did oh gosh no i got yelled at by a
couple people yeah
including me no that's a little weird
it's a little dahmer-esque i just
thought it was interesting
yeah on amazon no there's different
websites that like are they dark web or
legit they're just
real websites not like ebay human
remains.org basically like i think i
didn't want to think like one of them
was like bone room or something which
sounds kind of the bone room
can you even have
[Laughter]
yes
well it's been uh such a ride it's been
a joy and it's been a pleasure to meet
both of you
thank you thank you i'm so happy that
you came it was very nice to have you
here as well
summer break oh good yeah officially
and um um
keep slamming i really like the idea we
just cooked up about the gatsby the
destructive gatsby
just the force of because it is really a
force of destruction
yeah so i think that would be a really
fun video
people love destruction yeah i do yeah
it's just it's too easy to watch
you could let's do it yeah
oh i let's [ __ ] do it cool
that's the plan destroy things for the
gatsby yeah that's
very much up williams alley
just not in our house please yeah we can
do it uh where can we do it we'll have
to maybe we should just
there's like a place in the desert that
i like to go to
oh the desert's a good one or like a big
parking lot you could find somewhere
like just a parking lot yeah
walmart parking lot that's [ __ ] crazy
what are you gonna do
because i wanna mount like walls like a
drywall yeah and just like
and then like then like a thicker wall
like a sheet
of wood could use a youtube space you
think they would let us
well you sort of just got to explain
what you're doing in like a more
like professional scientific manner i
mean that william did the explaining
we're gonna test the failure mode of the
mobility scooter
like we're gonna crush it with the gas
don't worry we're gonna need the biggest
room you have and just leave us alone
yeah unless you just crash
into the wall
oh i'm looking forward to that and
congratulations on two million subbies
too
by the way that's great it's awesome i
don't know how i feel about it
it's there i didn't even know it's great
like whatever so oh really
i'm glad yeah all right guys well um
thank you all so much for watching it's
been a privilege and a pleasure
and uh today's friday so have a great
weekend actually saturday because this
comes out on saturday even though we're
filming on friday
you get it and um we'll be back next
week
the week after that we have oliver tree
right no
no oh i keep failing on you
no no well whatever you guys will just
figure it out
he's uh a month basically a month from
today okay
mid mid july is when he's coming because
his album was delayed
okay that's it that sounds great
well guys that's really all there is to
say
and um i'll leave you with this
potent um this potent message
h3h3 is [ __ ] innocent
thank you everybody that was the most
like
low energy
[Music]
baby
[Music]
[ __ ]